And we're live. What's up dude? How
are you? Good, Joe, how are you?
Oh, very good. Good to see you. Um,
for folks who don't know the story,
uh,
Michael as he prefers to be discussing,
talk to as directed as
a referred to as you,
uh,
you were a cop in Baltimore and you,
you put a string of tweets
that, uh, I read, uh,
that was on Huffington Post. And, uh,
that's when I got interested in this
whole story because it's very rare that
someone who's a cop comes out and tells
about all the shit that they experience.
Um, I have friends that are cops. Um,
and I know there's a lot
of good cops out there,
just like there's good everything,
you know, there's, you know,
a Sam Harris and I'm Dan Carlin just
did a podcast recently together.
It's a really excellent podcasts. And one
of the things they were talking about,
we were talking about people in power,
people that were our politicians,
that they, those are the whole
spectrum. You get great people,
people that are genuinely trying to do
good and you also get psychopaths. Um,
it seems like you ran into a
lot of fucking psychopaths.
How long were you a comp for?
I was a cop for 11 years.
But you look like you're 20. Thanks.
How's that possible? I don't know.
Good genetics, good genetics. And I guess
she did this trust didn't fuck with you.
It didn't really, really honest.
How did it not, my idea of, of,
uh, what an officer should be
was to be more robocop ish.
Like where I took my emotions out of
the job and handled it strictly as
enforcing the law. So if I was spit on,
I realized they weren't spitting at me,
they were spending at the uniform.
It was just irrelevant.
I understood it wasn't personal, so
I separate it. That as like a, a,
a role maybe like I was acting.
That's a great attitude to
have, I guess. Um, uh, was it,
does that something that you thought
about before you became a cop or is it
something you cultivated
while you were a cop?
I can't say for sure,
but it seems like,
I actually think that
was a wrong way to think.
But if you analyze it and you're
at that time, you think, well,
how am I not going to be biased?
I'm not going to be biased by,
by separating myself from the situation
and kind of acting as autonomous.
Right.
But I think that that also made me blind
because if I was being blind to racism
than I was being blind to when we were
doing it, even if I wasn't doing it,
I wasn't seeing it when it occurred
either because I was really literally
blinding myself to it.
So you're saying that if you
were blind to racism against you,
then you were also blind to cops
that were committing racism.
So if I looked at it as whether my,
whether I was talking to somebody of
Latino descent of black or whatever,
male,
female,
I looked at them just
as equally regardless.
So if you do that,
then you don't see that
you're disproportionately
enforcing things against
somebody because I'm literally
not trying to see that. Hmm.
So That's interesting.
So by,
by trying to treat everyone as equal,
you weren't taking a count of how many
black people you were dealing with.
How many Latinos you were dealing with,
how many people of color,
how many minorities is
that fair assessment? Yeah,
it is fair to the extent that, I'll
admit that I, when I was in, uh,
in the eastern district,
I would intentionally lock white
people up so that I could make sure my,
my numbers weren't like, like my squad.
It wasn't like, oh my gosh, look,
they look up 95% African Americans.
I didn't want to see that.
I wanted to see some kind of ballot.
So I was like aware that, hey,
we're locking too many black
people up, but I don't think I, it,
it just didn't compute at the time.
It takes time for it to settle in.
So what about those poor white
people that you locked up on purpose?
I've got nothing to do with a guilty
at least. Yeah. Yeah, of course.
I never locked the pay by, wasn't
guilty. Well, that's good. But you,
you experienced a lot of shit.
I mean, some of the things
that I read, um, that uh,
okay, here's one punting,
a handcuffed face down,
suspect in the face after a foot chase.
I'm pissing and shitting inside suspects
homes during raids on their beds and
close jacking up and illegally searching
thousands of people with no legal
justification.
This is crazy, man. This
is crazy stuff. Well, when,
when you're doing it, it's
just what police do you know
it, you've seen it on TV,
you've seen it driving by.
You've seen a corner full of black
guys with the cops searching them.
You've seen him.
And when they're going into those pockets,
you can't go into his pocket. You simply
can't. But we do. And not allowed to.
Right? You have no way of doing it
unless you're, you're getting a,
a frisk where you have,
you can justify Plainfield doctoring
and then you can get into the pocket.
But that's extremely rare.
I mean that,
that's a specific set of
circumstances under a Terry stop.
And that's nothing that
you see Harry stop.
So Terry versus Ohio was a
case law that established,
I could be slightly
off on the particulars,
but if somebody was displaying the
characteristics of an armed person and you
had suspicion or a hunch that
criminal activity was afoot,
you could stop that person.
And conduct a frisker the outer garments.
So how to garments, right? So
just the pat down essentially.
So the outer garments being
a jacket right at jacket.
So if you had, if, if like you thought
there they had a weapon on their hip,
you could pull back the jacket
and kind of pat it down.
But it seems as the law is written,
it would have to,
you'd have to even like squish it and
it's just what you can touch from the
outside.
So if you padded the outside of the jacket
and felt a gun that was in his waist,
then you could, you could arrest
him or take that gun, right?
You're perfectly fine, but you can't
dig in his pockets and look for crack.
Right? Well you can if you have
what that's playing field doctrine.
So if through my expertise I can tell
that that is packaging that is consistent
with,
that are distributed
in the area and I can justify that,
then I can go and retrieve those
narcotics that that's an extremely,
I mean if you can just think about that.
How do I really know that that bag in
your pocket is marijuana, not Oregano.
It's, it's I, I don't, I'm not sure if
that should be legally justified or not.
So that stop and Frisk Shit that
they were doing in New York,
they're not doing that anymore,
right? Isn't that the deal?
We talked about that on a podcast once we,
we went over all the times that it was
just innocent people and it's fucking
staggering. It's disgusting. That stopped.
They would just be able to pull white,
I mean, black kids. I said, why
kids? Not really though. Right.
It was mostly black kids. They would just
be able to pull them over and go, hey,
let me,
let me check you,
and they would just check their bodies
and most of the time they were innocent.
Most of the time there
was nothing to check for.
I'm going to tell you that 99.99999%
of them have nothing on them because
they're not even usually documented.
So in Baltimore will do stop and Frisk,
stop and Frisk.
You have to conduct an entire specific
report called a stop and Frisk report
that justifies everything you did and,
and so it's a big pain.
So no one's going to write that.
So they just do it and they move on.
So your stance or any
style you see as junk, so,
and the stats that you see that are junk,
sit there and say one in a thousand
actually have something on them.
So think about what reality is
Jesus. Um, what,
what led to you leaving the police
force and was this a buildup?
W was it something that you
thought about for a long time?
Hey, ready? Laugh. Yes. Okay.
We had a shooting range in the
basement of the eastern district.
We had to move something. Uh, we had
to put one desk on top of another desk.
It's slipped and I tore my shoulder out.
There's your exciting story for why
I left. That's it. That's it. What,
what was the injury? I had my shorter
reconstruct. It just tore at Tor. I,
it's where everything out and had to put
it back together. I'm like, what? What?
No Mountain. So the rotator cuff,
not rotator cuff. And so the,
the uh,
cartilage that folds over just doesn't
hold it into place anymore so it can come
out easily.
So if it can come out easily,
they don't let you be a cop anymore
and they process it can come out easily
right now.
Yeah.
So it's permanent forever department and
it's fucked up from moving a desk? Yes.
All the paradigms. The story.
I've got nothing. I have nothing.
Um, so you left and then you
decide how long ago was this?
I got injured in like late 2009
but it took time to do the surgery.
He's trying to come back.
I mean I tried to come back.
I came back and I was going code it
to a call with lights and sirens.
Went to turn down a street
and the shoulder popped out.
So I went up onto the sidewalk is I
had to grab it with the other hand and
that's when I had to go back in and then
they said I need another surgery is not
doing another surgery. So
from a fucking turn. Wow.
Fuck Cain Velasquez,
surgeon fixed that dude up.
Pretty good I guess. Um,
so you decided once you were out,
once you knew you were out,
you'd done the surgery,
you,
you couldn't be a police officer
anymore cause you shoulder blows out.
What made you decide to go
public with all this stuff?
Well I've actually talked about this
for a long time. Um, when I have,
we had a lot of local media and a local
street reporters and stuff like that
that I was friends with on Twitter and
we would talk about these things for the
last couple of years. We would just go
back and forth talking about things.
And I had no idea that
anybody would pick up on this.
I thought I was just going to be talking
to the same reporters in the same local
group of people that I've been
talking to the whole time.
So I came back and saw that
somebody started paying attention.
And what was that like
for you? Shocking. Yeah,
we were talking about it before the
show started. This new found notoriety.
How weird it is.
Like describe it.
Uh,
when we landed in La,
guy asked if I was on TV talking about
police and it's like, I don't know,
I'm used to being anonymous.
So I'm used to just going in,
minding my own business
and not bothering anybody.
And then suddenly people know who you
are. It's, it's, it's, it's awkward.
And especially for what they know you are,
because every time now a cop looks at
me, I'm like, yeah, it's, it's going to,
I'm the bad guy now,
so I can't trust them as well.
It makes it kind of a, I'm kind
of stuck in a, in a weird place.
So when this most recent Baltimore,
uh,
incident took place,
the Freddie gray incident,
the eruption of public attention on
police brutality in Baltimore and the
marches and all the new stories,
then people start really paying
attention to you. Is that fair to,
yeah. I mean, it seems
like that was the case.
I maybe somebody had followed me before
and somebody with a powerful retweet.
I have no idea.
And so what was the, explain how it all
went down. Like how did you become this
public figure?
I mean,
I literally have no
comprehension of what happened.
I decided that I was just going to talk
about some of the things we do so that
it's like, look, this is what we do. Let's
not try to pretend that we don't do it.
We do it.
So it's not about whether we're going
to blame the cops that did it or whether
we're going to go back
and have retribution.
We need to realize that this
is what we do. Stop denying it.
The black community has been
lying for the last 50 years.
We need to fix it and in a realistic
scientific way and where we have some
empathy and treat people like
human beings because we don't,
what is Baltimore like to someone whom I,
my buddy,
my buddy John Rollo lives in
Baltimore. Shout out to John Rollo. Um,
he loves to the podcasts all the time.
And the way he describes it is,
I mean I've been there a few times for
the UFC, but uh, I haven't, you know,
gone into the bad neighborhoods.
I didn't wash the wire. So,
but watching this,
this whole incident and seeing these
people talk about how many times they've
been arrested and how many times they've
been fucked over by cops and how crazy
it is there and how much
crime there was there
and how much violence there is there.
Um,
what it's like trying to grow up there
and become a normal person and what a
fucking uphill struggle that is described
Baltimore to somebody like me. Okay.
So Baltimore,
like anywhere else is largely good,
but it has a microcosm of it.
It's like the prototype
for the prison cycle.
So somebody comes up in a neighborhood
and they just have no hope and they keep
feeding that school to prison cycle over
and over and over again and has a deep
history in Baltimore.
So it invades everything.
So whether you're talking about are the
things that police do or whether you're
talking about where they live in
Baltimore, the, you have clusters,
so you'll have a, a black neighborhood
here, a black neighborhood here,
black neighbor here, white money, white
money, white money, low income white,
and it's in these clusters.
But these clusters were intentionally
formed by the law, uh, in Baltimore.
I can't even say how long ago,
maybe a hundred years ago.
And you still have deeds now that say
you can't sell the house to an African
American person. So like even if you
were a doctor there, you couldn't,
if you were a black doctor,
you couldn't buy a house in Nice
white neighborhood six years ago.
So you had to still go buy a house in
that little area and that if you're,
if you're a clustering,
everybody like that,
it just pulls everybody down constantly.
Constantly, constantly. It's like, it's,
they're just constantly beat down.
There's just no way out. So 60 years ago,
60 years ago,
you couldn't buy a house if you were
a black guy in certain neighborhoods.
And it was a law.
They had this on that it wasn't a deeds.
There's still some of the
deed still have it still. Why?
They know court's gonna uphold it,
but you'll still see it.
You'll see it in there.
So you'll see the language.
So if there's a white neighborhood today,
there's,
there's a possibility that some black
person who wants to move into this white
neighborhood might encounter
some resistance because of this.
I don't know if they're
going to count a resistance,
but they're going to see it in the deed
that's going to make you feel awkward.
Fuck. Why is it still in their
cases, the original deed?
They keep carrying it over. Know why
wouldn't they change that? I don't know.
I don't,
I have no idea why this city is that way,
why these people did these things.
It doesn't make sense.
Nobody stood up objectively and we
created these racist institutions. I mean,
they are institutional racism.
There's no doubt about it.
And it's up and down in these urban
environments and these cities, Cleveland,
Ferguson, Baltimore, Atlanta, it's
irrelevant. They're all the same.
All these urban environment and there's
all over Compton, watts. And go would,
there's a ton of places like that in
La as well. It's all over the world.
I mean all over the United
States I should say.
There's neighborhoods like that
that seem almost inescapable.
Digitas and the Malmo on
radio lab. Yes, I did. Okay.
You know how long back
that gives me think.
I mean this is so we're
denying that we have this so,
so well people are saying
these cops aren't racist.
Not saying they are racist when I'm
telling you is they're participating in
institutionalized racism.
Just like everybody in Britain was doing
back in Kenya with the mouse however
long ago that was. That was
a long time ago. And you're,
you're seeing it come out
how it's just the whole
thing. If you're participating
in it, you're guilty.
And that's what I'm telling you.
I'm guilty. I participated in it.
It is there a way to fix it?
Well,
the easy thing from the police thing
is I think empathy is number one.
We had to start treating human
beings like they're human beings.
We have to like we just arrest them and
you throw him in a cage just like they
did with Freddie Gray and you don't
focus on them being somebody's child or,
or, or, or your, I mean,
race is a social construct.
This is my brother and I'm doing
this to him. Eventually just doesn't,
it's inconceivable.
Um,
uh,
W we've had this conversation a hundred
times in this podcast where I have
always wondered why is it that we put
so much emphasis in trying to repair
damage that we've done in other countries.
So much emphasis in nation building,
so much emphasis in invading places
because of whatever perceived threat or
whatever natural resource we
want to dominate and monopolize.
But no emphasis whatsoever in
fixing our own inner cities.
No emphasis whatsoever and fixing the
ghettos and just constructing social
center is giving people places that are
safe to go to and somehow or another
educating people and, and, and,
and lifting them out one by one out of
the fucking constant cycle that they're
in this never ending cycle of poverty
and crime and being surrounded by it.
Man, you, everyone knows that
people imitate their atmosphere.
It's just a part of being a human being.
That's why accents exists.
That's why people in some parts of the
world do weird things because everyone
around them does it. Like, you know,
weird clothes that they
wear a weird rituals,
scarring of their face. You
know, what have you, that
we imitate what's around us.
And when you're around a lot of fucking
crime and you grow up around a lot of
fucking crime and a lot of people
with records, criminal records,
and it becomes normal. And I don't
know how to fix that and I don't,
I don't see any effort whatsoever in
really engineering some sort of a solution
to what these poor,
unfortunate people are born into.
Well, for police it's even worse because
we're perpetuating that situation.
So work,
we're the ones doing that cycle.
So when we see a 61 time I was a shift
commander in the eastern district and I'm
telling my guys,
stop pulling over old white ladies.
Stop pulling over that young cute girl.
Stop.
We focus on who committed the crimes
and who commit the crimes. In Baltimore,
16 to 24 year old black males.
That's who's committing the crimes.
So focus on them.
That makes sense.
Until you complete the cycle and realize
that you started doing that because of
institutionalized racism
in your organization.
And so when you are jacking up those
guys in the corner and you do find that
dime bag, so sent him to jail, now
he can't go to work the next day.
So he loses his job and then
he can't make it to court.
So he gets his license suspended and then
he's driving and then you are focusing
on those 1624 black male. So now
you're more likely to pull them over.
Now you pull him over.
Now he has a suspended license.
Now he gets his license is revoked and
now he can't get to the job legally and
you just, and now, now he's dealt. It's
left with selling drugs on the corner.
So you were were creating it.
We have to step back and realize what
the facts are and what we're doing.
And then the number one
problem is the drug war.
And then we have money in politics.
Those are our two big issues that we have
to solve before we get anywhere. Well,
what does the money in
politics has a player.
So I don't think we can change anything
until we stopped having politicians that
are serving their donors
versus serving the people.
So somebody that's talking like me is
never going to run a police agency as long
as all their corporate donors
are saying, no, no, no.
You keep those animals and the cages
because that's what they do. I mean,
that's a good joke in Baltimore that
police are actually the zookeepers.
She keeps everything in it. Don't
let it hit the county. So, so that's,
that's our role.
That's what we're doing.
So your mayors and your politicians are
going to continue to encourage that.
They're not going to take a risk and say,
all right,
how do we lower juvenile possession of
marijuana? You know that I know you do.
You know you legalize it. Yeah. And you
control it. And rates actually go down.
Whether we're overseas
or were in Colorado,
your possession rates for marijuana
will go down among juveniles.
But we don't do that.
We keep looking at everything like we're
hammer searching for nouns and we keep
looking for what we're
going to hit to stop it.
Instead of standing back and using science
and figuring out what are we actually
going to do to fix this problem,
what we'll actually have results.
This is a very rare to hear
a cop talk like this. I'm,
I'm really happy that you're coming
forward and speaking like this,
but how many people that were with you
in the police force or upset about this?
My closest friends,
I think understanding.
I think the vast majority is upset with
me and they're going to be upset with me
because what I'm really trying to do
is take power away from them. I mean,
I really am.
I'm trying to take power from them and
give it back to the people because we're
supposed to be serving them.
We're not supposed to be this occupying
force and this pretty little white boy
from the county looks like an
occupying force in the city.
There's no way around it, so I have to
be aware of that and think about that.
Think about what I'm doing.
Not being an occupying force,
essentially actually go out of my way
to lift up a situation to deescalate it
and do better than the, come in there
and be like, you're going to jail,
you're going to jail. Shut up, let's
go. Which is what I did for a long time.
So when you say the county,
what does that mean?
When you say white boy from the county.
What's the county? So the suburbs,
so in Baltimore it's kind of weird.
It's a little different.
So Baltimore's incorporate it.
So has nothing to do with the county.
So there's like this hard line.
So it's not lawyer and then the county
of Baltimore County. Oh, okay. Right.
So you have the city by itself.
So here in Los Angeles,
do you think you have marina Delray, you
have Inglewood. You have all this stuff.
Is Is La in Baltimore?
It's just Baltimore.
So everything is concentrated and focused.
And me coming from the county,
I've never spent any time
in the city growing up.
I come in just as straight from the
Marine Corps that's ready to roll.
We're going to do our thing.
Uh,
I'm going to put on a different
uniform and continue my war.
Wow. So that was, that
was why he became a cop.
So you came right from the military
and it just seemed like a logical
progression.
It's a logical progression.
I think I went into the Marine Corps
to prepare myself. I was a little, uh,
uncontrolled and decided to go into the
Marine Corps to get my shit together and
discipline mass if I could get into the
police department and everything would
be,
and that was my always my goal.
So your goal was always to be a
police officer, right. Why was that?
I Dunno. Said it since
I was a little kid. Uh,
I think you go in with these grandiose
ideas that you're going to help people
and, and maybe that's why I talk.
I mean, it's still evolving then I,
then I'm saying these things,
so you're,
you're bringing up a point
and maybe that's why I taught.
Maybe I feel that I wasn't doing
what I actually set out to do.
I was actually exacerbating the situation.
So you got caught up
in the cycle yourself.
The cycle of law enforcement and the
way law enforcement behaves in Baltimore
and it just became habitual.
Totally. You don't think about it, you
just ignore it. So when I say that, uh,
I had that suspect that I chased and the
guy comes up and kicks him in the face.
I think to myself, God, that
guy is a fucking asshole,
but not me.
I didn't do it right.
But I have the responsibility
to do something there.
That was an assault on an innocent victim.
It's not as bad as McKinney,
but it's assault on an innocent victim
that I should have certainly stepped up
and done something about it. It's just,
you were, you were in it. You don't it,
I can't explain it how you don't see it
until you've really just start to slowly
step back and say,
what are we doing here?
We're starting to see more and more,
um,
videotapes s police stories of,
of police brutality.
Do you think this is just a result of
cell phones or is the violence escalating
or is the violence always
been there like this,
but people are finally
finding out about it?
I think it's actually deescalating
the violence. Yeah, I think you're,
I think your cell phones are
certainly scaring a lot of cops from,
from doing things. But the only variable
here is the proliferation of videos,
a video cameras. So as you get more and
more cameras, you're seeing more and more.
But imagine what it was like before the
camera's cops know the cameras are there.
We've known it for a long time.
So like we have pole cameras in
Baltimore and so if we were going to do
something on,
so there's a street called monument street
that's full of these cameras that are
monitored by the city. So
as an officer, I always knew
that if I was on that street,
I kind of had to behave in a,
in a different manner because
I knew the camera was there.
Now we know that the camera's
there all the time, so it's,
it's gotta be much smaller.
Well, there's always these guys,
they say that you can't even
believe they're real humans.
Like that fucking cop and Texas.
It showed up at the pool party
and did the fucking role.
Like he's Paul Blart Mall Cop.
Holy fucking shit.
When you find out that that's a real
person, you just like, wait. So,
so think about that situation.
So that's the McKinney situation where
you have a guy assaulting a 14 year old
girl and that chief still comes
out and still he has that blinder,
that blue blinder where he's
saying there's 11 good cops
there. My ass, there are,
there are 12 bad cops there.
Cause he just witnessed an assault on a
14 year old girl in a bathing suit and
did shit about it.
So you have 12 bad cops.
But the reason why I'm talking is because
I do think there's 11 other ones can
be spoken to.
I think the guy that comes up and pats
him on the back then it was like, Yo,
what are you doing?
Why is your gun out?
If we keep talking to him then maybe he'll
be able to go talk to two more people
maybe who realized what he's doing.
And we can kind of,
at least on a grass roots level kind
of changed what police think they're
supposed to be versus what we are.
We've talked about it on the podcast
many times that I think that it's one of
the most difficult jobs
that a person can do.
And one of the jobs that has the least
amount of respect cops like almost
routinely are treated with
disrespect and also they're there.
No one,
no one thinks about PTSD for cops.
People think about it all the time when
it comes to soldiers is become much more
in the public eye.
But the amount of stress that's,
that's a part of being a police officer.
What does that,
like when you're going into these bad
neighborhoods and you're dealing with
murder,
when you're dealing with
all sorts of different assaults and
domestic violence and theft and robbery,
like what is that like to be a person who
deals with that every day and how much
of a factor does that play in
these people snapping on people?
This is hard for me to say because
I don't feel like I had that. Um,
I did not find the job
stressful on the streets. Uh,
the greatest enemy was from within.
Uh, they say that and then to watch,
don't worry about street.
You got to worry about what the other
officers are doing. I missed that too.
I thought it was good. Yeah,
that was good. It was a, the,
the banter back and forth and then movie
is very realistic of what cops act like.
You think cops are all professional,
but we're sitting in the car talking
about the same things and anybody else
talks about and then you're, oh shit,
something's going on mostly pussy, right?
Yeah. Anyway, so where were we?
We were talking about how
stressful it is. Right? It's not,
it wasn't stressful for me. Are
you a Weirdo? I don't think so.
I think I built up that wall and
to do other people have that wall.
Not all of them. I knew some of them
handled things, uh, more personally.
So they take, I don't think
we want those people as cops.
I understand it's hard for them. I get
that. But the job's not for anybody.
You're absolutely right. When you say
the job is nearly impossible. I think it,
it is impossible to do.
Right?
So that's why we have to be more human so
that when we screw up, we can say, look,
I screwed up and this is why.
And people will understand where you're
coming from. Whereas with Freddie Gray,
we obviously screwed up.
There's no way around this,
but yet we still come out and be like,
oh, but we don't know anything. We're to,
the facts are out bullshit. You had
somebody in your possession and he's dead,
stopped denying it.
No.
What was all the bullshit about him having
a neck injury that turned out to not
be true? Right. That's
how it was all bullshit.
Was it just something somebody made up
online? Is that what you would think?
He had an old car accident or something
like that and the case had some kind of
final disposition that was entered into
the court records, but it was that,
it was harking back to
something a long time ago.
So he died from being slammed up against
the wall inside the back of a paddy
wagon. Right. So that's what happened.
And what was he arrested for? Okay,
so let's think about, let's
put this in real terms. Okay.
Police always want to put things in legal
terms, but you're in a high drug area.
Uh,
lieutenant sees Freddie Gray,
well allegedly sees Freddie gray
recognize him, turn and run.
So they chase, they follow him,
they catch him, they searched him.
And do we have a stop and Frisk? No,
they didn't document a stop and Frisk.
So because he's running,
does that mean that he,
there's these suspicious.
So believe it or not,
the law says that that's fine, that
you can chase him and you can stop him.
So my immediate objection with that case,
I don't know why I can't think of it
off top of my head, but that case,
there's no clarification on how
much force is allowed to be used.
So in a stop and Frisk, you can actually
use a, a legitimate amount of force.
But in that situation,
the running, I don't,
I don't really know how much
force is allowed to be used there.
So I was curious how much force they use.
But apparently they didn't use that much
force and they searched him and they
got a knife out of his pocket.
So let's stop at this knife.
Now how do we get into the knife?
We searched it went into his pocket.
We don't have, we don't have
a stop and Frisk. Right?
But even if you can somehow
justify that the knife that he has,
his only illegal if it
has an internal spring.
So how could you feel whether it had an
eternal spring or not and how many white
people do you think carry a
knife on the internal spring?
It's going to be the same amount. But
do any of them ever get arrested? Never.
The internal spring.
So fucking stupid.
They have thumb releases for knives now
that are easier than a switch blade.
The whole thing is stupid.
So why do you create a law like that?
You create a law like that because you
can fuck with the people that you want to
fuck with.
That's why we do it because they saw
west side story and something like that.
Switch plates back and then
now everybody's scared to
switch late in high school.
I thought it was a bad ass, but then
I realized like it's just a knife,
a regular knife. It's like a better
tool. Like that switch plates,
fucking stupid spring
breaks, it folds up. So this
guy had a switchblade, is that,
well, well we haven't seen
the knife yet, but by we have,
they don't even mean a switchblade
with they're saying is,
so you have an assistant
so you have a flip out.
You know how some of them you have
to use your whole force, right?
And so some of them are assistant and
assistant pocket knife. It's this big,
it was illegal in Baltimore.
But I assure you that everybody that's
been arrested with that is 98% going to
be black.
So the users and excuse absolutely.
So we can fuck with who we want to
fuck with. It's exactly what we did.
So his knife was essentially
like a utility knife that
people might have in that
if you live in a hood [inaudible]
probably you might have an iPhone yet.
Probably a good idea. Yeah.
So if I would've called him,
well I would probably chased him
because I think he was dealing,
I would have chased him. Right.
But I would have stopped him.
He didn't have the drugs on
him. He wins. I searched him.
I probably do take out the knife, but
I give it back to him and I say, okay,
be safe. Sorry about that. And we're
good. We're playing the game. We know.
Did it bug you that you were looking
for drugs? Did that ever like go,
what the fuck am I doing?
Being some sort of a glorified
revenue collector for the state,
pulling people over and g for drugs.
Yeah,
you're totally right.
There is no point in any consensual
daughter grievance to fight against them.
But, but my whole point is to
keep it real. It was fucking fun.
It was fun. It was fucking great fun
to catch him. I live for the car chase.
I mean,
you think about this,
think about if you're in a police car
and you have the lights and sirens and
you're going down like coastal highway,
or you're going down your favorite
one oh one or whatever it is,
and you're gone through your side
roads and you're chasing this guy.
There is no adrenaline rush.
It's ever compared to that.
It you live for it. It's,
it's incredible. It's amazing.
And you don't really, I,
I didn't really care why gimme the
car chase. It was, it was amazing.
That's so refreshing.
The honest.
I'm so glad you're talking like this
because I always thought that too.
I was felt like they, it must be exciting
for them. Like a fucking is amazing.
Cheetah chasing the gazelle.
Right? Well, it's a three good stories
we could tell later on that. I mean,
it's just like, oh, you can understand
if you're in that situation.
Is that one of the reasons
why so many cops shoot people?
It's like the idea of the rush of being
in a gun fight of the rush of finding
someone who deserves to get shot.
You know it's like when you're hunting,
all right,
you're,
you know you see animals that you're
not supposed to shoot but I swear to God
there's a party.
Fucking Brandon wants to shoot a squirrel.
It was like a 300 win mag.
You don't do it but there's a part of
your brain you like, you have a rifle.
He looked into the crosshairs squirl
doesn't even know you're there.
You don't do it.
But there's a part of you that wants to
and I'm like why does that even exist?
Because people like hitting targets.
The same reason why you like going to
the range and shooting at those steel
targets.
Like why do you like,
because people like hitting things
with guns cause you have a gun.
Like you said when you have a hammer
everything looks like a nail and when you
were in your cop car and someone takes
off whether or not it makes sense to
chase him, it must feel like the right
thing to do. Right? Like your instinct,
I'm going to go with you on the car chase.
I'm not going to go with you
on the shooting for like was I
looking for the target? Yeah, I was,
you know, if I had a guy with a knife,
I was sitting there, I was telling
him, put it down, put it down,
but in my head I'm of fuck, don't put
it down. You want them to come out,
shoot him fucking cop. I'm
going out there. You know?
It's like this is what you do, but,
but you had a line for I, yeah,
and I go to across it.
I certainly was going across,
I was ready to shoot if I had to,
but I was never going to cross that line.
You kind of wanted to shoot.
Sure. Wow. I killed it.
I come from the Marine Corps. I was in
fast team. Right. This is what I did.
I was trained from 17 I went to marine
court 17 I was handed a rifle in bootcamp
and I went into special ops and I was
trained day in and day out to kill.
That's,
that's the honest truth.
And then I have to transition
into bringing those skills,
that skill set into a police department
where luckily I was able to separate
myself and it wasn't an issue for me,
but I don't think that's where
the shooting has come from.
I'm pretty convinced that your
military members actually won't shoot.
I'm convinced that the
shooting come from fear.
Uh,
that makes a lot of sense.
So the military members
have more discipline,
they've been through real war and they
understand shooting and death better.
Yeah. I think you just understand
the rules of engagement better.
Whereas the people that come
from civilian life, and you know,
there's a fucking video of this guy who's
this big fat slob who's a cop and a,
he's trying to get ahold of this guy
and the guy winds up beating his ass and
there's like this chaos
thing running around.
But I'm looking at that guy and I'm like,
this guy does not,
there's no way this guy should be
a fucking law enforcement officer.
He's just way to add a shape.
He's just way too
undisciplined. You know, his,
his body is just not
serving him correctly.
And he's involved in physical altercations
with criminals and to be a person
that is in day to day contact with people
that may or may not want to kill you,
you're like,
you have to have a certain amount of
awareness and you have to have a certain
amount of physical ability.
Yeah.
And you have to trust those abilities.
You have to realize that you're going
to be able to handle that situation.
I think it's easier in a city then it
would be for Pennsylvania state trooper or
something like, I don't know
what I would do in thirst shoes.
And they're stuck out in the middle
of nowhere by themselves in a city,
all you gotta do is hold on for 30
seconds, you're going to get help.
But how they do it in those environments,
baffling to me,
but they don't get into a lot of shootings
as much as urban environments because
I think it's that fear. But I think
as a nation we fear the black man.
He's the demon. So you saw that and
Mike Brown, when that cop says, oh,
he had a demons look in his eye
and the team is looking at it. I,
what are you talking about? Do you ever
see anybody say that Dylan roof? Oh,
he looked like he had a demon. Look in
his eye. They don't say that. They say,
oh this troubled youth, but
the black guys, the demon.
So we have that in our society
that that's the criminal.
So that's who we're looking at
and that's who we're fearing.
We're fearing the black men raping.
Our daughters were fearing that,
that whether we want to face it or not,
as a nation,
it's real and we have to face it.
If we want to learn how to police
properly and we actually want to get our
nation back to where it is and we
stopped and we tear down these borders,
these things that we do, these social
constructs, your flags, you're your,
whether we have a line now in Mexico so
that they can't come over here and we
don't help them. And, and we have
our states and we do all this other.
All so much dumb shit that we just
make up the separate ourselves,
but there's no difference. He's, he's
got more Melatonin than I do. Wonderful.
Whatever. They're just human
beings. We're all the same.
We know that scientifically. We know
this. I agree with you on that. But there,
the guy that shot the people in Colorado,
that was one of the first things I said,
does it, is he looked possessed. The, the,
his eyes were,
I mean,
I absolutely agree with you that
there is institutionalized racism.
Absolutely agree with you.
But I think anytime someone becomes
a school shooter or, I mean they,
they treat that person like there
are some psychopathic maniac.
Yeah,
I can see that.
Did you get into altercations
where you had to shoot people?
I could have pulled the
trigger justifiably, quite a
few times, but he never did.
No, no. 11 years in Baltimore in the city.
And he didn't have to shoot anybody.
No, no, no. I can't. I mean,
I know of two that were pretty happy.
I'm pretty close to me and that were
completely, completely clean shootings.
And again, it was an, it was an experiene.
Maybe I'm being biased. I don't know, but,
well, it makes sense to me. I don't
think you're being biased at all.
I would want someone who, first of
all, it's a logical progression.
If someone is looking for a good job
and they get out of the military,
it's a logical progression.
I would trust military members more than
I would trust the civilian has never
seen any, any real gunfire or
any, any real shit. You know,
someone who has never experienced any
sort of altercation like that and all of a
sudden being thrust into it, you just
got to hope they can keep it together.
I know some people can,
but a lot of people can't.
Someone who's been through the marine,
someone who's been through, you know,
anything, a navy seal, someone
who's been through war,
that person in my eyes is a much more
qualified candidate than the average
person.
It makes sense.
So when you're talking to me and you're
saying that you had a certain amount of
discipline and you had a sir,
but you're also being very honest
about you wanted them to come at you,
which I think is a natural human instinct.
I think it's very important that
you're talking like this. I really do.
Cause I think,
um,
there's a lot of people that would
shy away from talking like that,
especially someone who's still out of
a career in law enforcement. You know,
I think my, my hopes for resuming a career
in the US first, we are probably over.
Yeah.
And less
when it comes along and listens to this
with an open mind and realize is know
this fucking guy is exactly what we need.
And I think that is exactly what we need.
We need people like you and we
need people like you, other people
are going to listen to and say, well,
here's a guy who was on our side.
Here's a guy who's not a racist.
Here's a guy who's not just looking
to shoot people and lock people up.
Here's a guy who really came into this
job wanting to help and experienced a
bunch of fucking chaos. It's chaos.
There's no other better word for it. It's,
it's the biggest shit show you'll see is
going to an urban environment and being
thrust in that because you were,
it's not just, that's just saying,
it's not just a street.
It's internal as well.
The whole thing is a big cluster fuck of
mismanagement and no one's caring about
what we actually need to do.
We need to end the damn drug war.
This is ridiculous that we're doing this.
So that's most of what you're
arresting people for. Oh Gosh, I don't,
was it all of it?
90 90% Jesus fucking Christ.
How crazy is that? How crazy is
that? 90% that's all that matters.
There is guns and drugs, guns
and drugs, guns and drugs,
guns and drugs and guns
probably are there.
So they could sell drugs and
defend themselves. Defend
themselves, right? Yeah.
Fucking hey man. What a
crazy, crazy situation.
Just a bizarre police state set up
by the fact that drugs are illegal,
man. It does. I mean it
invades the entire thing.
So when we saw what happened with alcohol,
right?
So gangs takeover and you have violence.
Do you want to lower the violence?
Isn't that the mission of the police?
Do you want to lower the violence than
every single chief out there needs to be
saying, hey, we need to end
this drug war. Stop it. Yeah.
How many cops are saying
that we need to stop bars?
How about none there a single bar?
You know?
And that's what causes all the fighting.
We all know that if they were
all sitting around smoking,
they've nothing would have happened.
But also I support their right to get
fucked up if they want. You know, I'm,
I've been drunk a lot and I've
never heard anybody. Never,
never did anything fucked up. Never cause
any crimes. Never heard anybody. Never.
You know,
I just don't think that human,
I think human beings should be able
to do whatever the fuck they want.
I think when you,
when you violate somehow or another,
you violate either other people's
rights or other people's safety or other
people's health and welfare,
then it becomes a real issue and you
should be prosecuted based on whatever
transgressions you've committed.
Right.
So don't you agree then that the drug war
distracts you from actually being 100%
real police?
100% totally turned you away from it.
What kind of relationship did you have
with the people in Baltimore that you
would, your area, did
you develop friendships?
Did you develop any sort of
connection with those folks? None.
I was an occupying force. I handled my
stuff and I went out because so so to,
to know you. If you were
in my neighborhood, I would
have to stop and talk to you.
I mean, I'd have to spend time with you.
I may even have to talk to your kids.
We could shoot the shit on the
corner or something like that.
But the whole time I'm doing that,
the the departments are going to actually
be criticizing me and I'm not doing my
job. Because you're not writing tickets,
not pulling people over. You're not,
you don't, you're not meeting your
quotas. I'm not getting my stats.
I'm not making the arrest
that I need to make. So I was,
I came out of the academy and went and
walked foot where Freddie gray is and the
Gilmore homes. So that was my first
foray. So I got solidified into this,
US versus them. You threw me right into
the biggest war zone. We have foot,
one foot. How many who,
who were you with another?
Another trainee that had no idea
what the hell he was doing. Either.
You didn't want to team up with two
others. So you're playing cops, right?
Totally playing. Wow. And we
were doing all drug arrests.
So we would go up and we would like go
and covert and into the projects because
the projects had heat
and it was wintertime.
So you could like break into one of the
doors and it had heat in it and then you
could watch what happened in the court
yard and people would sell and we would
have one of us would run down
out of the room, circle around.
So you would go and break into a room
because it had heat in it. Right?
Because their projects there, they, the
heat stays on. So it'd be an empty vacant,
a vacant apartment, right? Yeah.
And the heat would be all on
pick the lock or just kicking it.
You can't always find a way and
just pick a lock. You get a key.
There was always a way and
someone, someone else usually
already did it for you.
Right.
And we would watch them and like my first
arrests went down there and grab them.
And the first thing you
said was, uh, you know,
these aren't my pants because he
knew he had the drugs in them.
Pants. That's the first guy
you arrested. That's hilarious.
Boy Did you know you were
in for a fucking world of
what a great way to start off a career.
That's like the perfect way.
The first guy you arrest has,
these are not,
what is my first thing you I grab his arm.
So I go there and I go to the southern,
which is a area where it's, um,
you would be fascinated there.
I'm just going to be bluntly honest cause
that's the whole point of this is you
have a black ghetto,
you have white trash for the most part,
and then you have this cluster next
to it. A really good people, uh,
doctors,
lawyers,
just regular people that in that area
that are nice and they mingled together
and it's chaos.
So I go from that in chaos because college
kids that are going to university of
Maryland think that they can just
walk down the street and to the bad
neighborhood and everything will be fine.
They think they could drink and walk
down the street and nothing's going to
happen to them. Uh, the, the, what does
happen? They're going to get robbed.
They know it. We know. They didn't
know we knew it and he's like, Hey,
what are you doing? Don't do that. Uh,
the, the, the whites and the neighborhood,
you would have a really hard time
figuring out your reports because you were
supposed to put in like who the person's
relationship was and you're like, wait,
is it your cousin? Is that wait, you,
so he's your cousin and your uncle.
This isn't making sense. So what
block do I put? The guy that did it?
Was he your cousin or no, he
was your uncle. It's like, nope.
And everything was all together.
So like there's so much inbreeding really.
You actually, you would
have these crazy things, uh,
that you would have Hispanics that came
in and were trying to come up themselves
and it was all just go together.
It's chaos.
You can go there right now and it's just
a crazy societal test bed of everybody
coming together from these
entirely different backgrounds.
And there's real inbreeding.
Yeah. It's like super common.
Everybody knows it. Yeah.
Really?
What the fuck.
So I go from there and I go
to inbreeding is like you've,
we'd run into that every day.
Not every day. Once a week. Yeah.
Maybe if you're working there.
Hey Man.
So I go from there and I go
to the northern district,
which is this area
called Mount Washington.
Mount Washington is a
upperclass 80% to 90% white.
Uh, you have judges that lived
there, you have nice houses, 400,
$500,000 houses. And now I'm in
this environment and it's like,
Holy Shit, where am I?
Yeah, I'm in white land now.
I have this road that's
called cost country boulevard
and it has extreme next to
it.
What the hell am I doing here?
So I'm expected to get the same amount
of arrest and I'm Spec to write, take it.
So I have bosses that are telling me like,
you're not doing anything like, well,
what am I supposed to do? I'm like,
in a good neighborhood, what do I do?
So I would leave my area,
go to the black neighborhoods and make
drug arrests so that I could appease my
bosses with my arrest numbers. So you're
continuing that cycle. Once again,
I'm leaving that area to go poach and
specifically continue that cycle and I'm
doing it because that's what
I'm supposed to be doing.
So if you were in a place that had
no crime, you would get in trouble.
Yeah.
I had my one sergeant had to defend me
constantly because I went to a post in
that same district where I started
bringing the crime numbers down,
but I didn't have the arrests and he's,
he had to defend me to his
bosses saying like, look,
he hasn't had a part one a
serious crime it in a long time.
That's like that's his job.
And I was getting criticized the whole
time cause I didn't have as many rounds.
That's like the ultimate goal,
right, is to have no crime.
Shouldn't that be the metric that
should be, it's not a metric,
but if we all had no crime, like I,
I've also, I've often proposed this,
like if we had a moratorium on crime, if
the whole country got together and said,
all right, no one for the next month,
we can go 30 days without speeding.
30 days without illegal turns.
30 days without any violent crime,
30 days without any theft.
What would happen?
We'd probably make some up,
but make up some crops just
to arrest black people.
That's what reality is.
But that's what we should be.
So like my liberal idea of policing
would be to empower that officer.
That's one of the street.
So even if there wasn't crime,
than what he would really be doing is
making sure that the alley was cleaned up,
solving problems that
are in the neighborhood.
So whatever the problem could possibly
be,
you know,
there's this guy that constantly parts
on this corner and the street sweeper
can't get it. We'll fix all
those problems. So even if
you don't have crime, the,
the peace officer, the protector should
still have plenty of things to do.
So it shouldn't be just crime.
Crime should be an element
of, of what police did.
Did you have to pull over people and
write tickets for speeding and shit like
that? Or Walmart doesn't care
about that. They don't care. No.
You can just drive crazy pretty
much. Really? Yeah. There's,
there's no traffic cops or anything
like that in the city. What? Um, yeah,
it's just doesn't work that way. Um,
what, yeah, there's no traffic cops.
I mean maybe a district here,
there might have one guy that
kind of primarily does traffic,
but it's just patrol officers
are expected to handle traffic.
And again, remember I'm not being
judged on that, so why would I care?
Right.
So my car is not,
the only reason I do a car stop is to
get guns or drugs or maybe a warrant.
Like so.
So if I turn a plate right and the guy
has a warrant driver has a warrant,
then yeah, I'm going to do that. So
I'm not going to do it unless it's,
I haven't a possibility of an arrest.
I'm not going to sit there
and write bullcrap tickets.
Did you arrest the same guys more than
once? Yeah. Yeah, plenty of times.
Especially when I was doing narcotics.
So after I went from the northern,
I went to a unit called the
violent crime impact division,
and it was like plain clothes.
Got To have the tats out and be all tough
and run around like you are, you are,
you know,
they called knockers in the city.
And so from there you're dealing with
the shame street level dealers all the
time. And uh, uh, one of those
kids actually really struck me. Um,
maybe,
so a great irony that I had in doing
drug work is usually drug works makes you
sent you to the deeper into it.
And it actually pulled me out because I
would interview these guys in the little
rooms.
And this one guy,
Daniel Taylor is the one I'm specifically
remembering and he was just a,
a marijuana dealer and he had a kid
and he was struggling to have this kid.
He was young,
he was trying to help,
but he had gotten a locked
up a lot when he was younger.
So he was selling weed just
like buy diapers for his kid.
And he would tell me his stories and we'd
be there and he'd be crying and it was
just like, fuck, there's no difference
between this kid and me. There's nothing.
The only difference between this kid and
me is that when I had a dime bag in my
pocket, there wasn't a fucking chance in
hell. Someone was going to look but him,
he was going to get caught eventually
and it sent him into that spiral.
And this could have been a good kid and
I wouldn't be surprised if he was still
in jail now and there was just
nothing wrong with him. We,
our whole system created a criminal
out of a decent kid and it was,
it was shocking to me.
Like I,
I like I knew I was following the
rules and so I had to arrest him.
I had to finish this up because it was
doing what I'm supposed to be doing,
but it was kind of heartbreaking and start
to see that these people, they didn't,
they weren't different than us.
They just had a different environment
than us and we should be changing that
environment, not changing
them. So you felt this was,
so let me back up a bit.
This going into this district
and this new position,
why were you allowed to wear regular
clothes and what was the idea you're
supposed to blend in?
So the idea,
so you're supposed to have an advantage
to sneak up and all that. Then I also,
I haven't taught a quick funny story
about that, but you're a white guy.
This is really good. Sorry. I appreciate
it. Okay, so I that's always the struggle,
right? So the tattoos, blackface,
no, no. Stop it. So why is that bad?
I don't understand it. I really don't.
Go ahead and set the tats were out.
I had a red Mazda six with tinted windows,
Virginia tags cut off.
Sleeves was rolling down.
Thinking I was blending is Zit.
I look like I'm some buying.
This is going to be anything you consider
maybe like carving a lightening bolt
and your hair. She could
have done something crazy
just to look a little more.
It's kind of guy was out there
by like your trans racial perhaps
not opening that kid. They're there or
any open, you don't even have to dig in.
It's overflowing.
I don't have an opinion.
I'm so happy that girl's
alive and so happy.
Just debate is on and it gives you fodder.
Well, yes, I'm a fan of human folly.
So, so you're rolling around like a
white guy sticking out like a sore thumb
thinking I wasn't and it turned the corner
and literally I was like a four year
old boy. He's like, Yo dad
have knockers right there.
It just as good as I get.
This is all I have and I still could
blend it. So what was the point there?
So they knew that there was a position
that cops get into where they,
they're allowed to dress like normal
people called knockers in Baltimore.
And you called knockers by the police
department as well or just find out by the
civilians. Civilians. And why do
you think you're called knockers?
Obvious answer. Why knock heads. It's
what you do. Oh, I see. On the street,
you're the force.
You're the enforcement team.
So that's actually what it was
caused by enforcement team.
We went out there and stamp down the drug.
Is there pressure to be
intimidating to like to you must,
yes. You must be intimidating.
I wouldn't survive so,
so you can look at me and you can think
of me being in the wire and Jamie would
I have survived? If I was
not intimidating. No, no.
I wouldn't have survived and
still watch the wire. Goddammit.
So like a technique is actually
to find one of the biggest,
baddest dudes in your area and
kick his ass punk him. Yeah.
You have to use weapons or would
it? How you doing? No, no, no.
You're going to arrest him for something.
You're going to be a little rough with
him. You're going to do something to, uh,
cause he's the, he's the king
dog in that neighborhood. Right.
So you have to a certain the Alpha role.
If you don't do that,
you're gonna get run over. A lot of cops
don't do it. But if you don't do that,
you are not going to survive
in a drug unit for sure.
You're going to get trampled. Why do
you, why do you survive if you do do it?
I would think you're making an enemy.
Yeah. It's a battle. It's a war.
It's what it is. It's a drug war.
Don't be fooled. That's what it is.
That's what we've created.
It's so it's US versus them.
And if I'm going to be ahead, I have
to be the Alpha Dog. Right. You know,
I've never obviously never been a cop,
but I worked as a security guard
for a while at this concert place.
And one of the things that I've recognized
really early on was that there was a
US versus them mentality just from fucking
security guards at a concert place.
And I would imagine the US versus them
between cops and the people on the street
gets pretty fucking intense,
pretty big division.
And that is how you can have a black
officer who's participating in a racist
organization just like anybody else did.
You have a lot of black officers in
Baltimore is about, it's about even. Wow.
So,
but there's no difference.
Maybe even the black officers
a little bit more aggressive.
I have a theory on that, but I, well
that was an ice tea thing. Ice Tea,
you said talk about
that. And I said, yeah,
I think that's what they've always felt
that there was black cops that made up
for the fact that they were
black by being extra brutal.
And that's what they thought. I don't
actually think that that's why, uh,
it's conjecture but my part, but I
think that's because they're actually,
they feel embarrassed that those people,
they feel like,
like the black criminals are making the
black race, the black community look bad.
So that kind of like extra angry.
Whereas I'm not going to be angry
because I don't care. Oh, I see. Huh.
Maybe it could be a little bit
of both or either or. Certainly.
So for different people. Wow. What the
fuck dude? What a crazy life you lived.
Yeah, I didn't think of it. I looked at
the time. Right. But now being out of it,
how long did it take before you
realize how fucking crazy it was?
It started when I was in, but it started
with like talking to that kid that was,
and then I would also sit and covert
and watched. So you'll love this.
And one time I was,
we were doing a long investigation and
I had this vacant building that I would
hide in.
A homeless dude was there and a homeless
dude with like leave magazines for me.
And then like I would come in during
the day and he would come in at night.
It was the weirdest exchange.
We never crossed paths though.
You would leave magazines for yeah, yeah,
yeah. It's the worst cop monthly. No, no,
no.
It was a cop.
I think he legally playboy or he'd lean
times or something like that whenever he
had. And he knew I was
there. I knew he was there,
but we never actually crossed paths.
But they had a,
so he left them for you though? Yeah,
man. We both knew we were there and uh,
he had a, if there was a big, huge
picture of Jesus filling the window,
and so I carved out Jesus's eyes
and I would stand behind him.
And that's how I watched so
double meaning Jesus Christ.
So I was actually standing
[inaudible] watch it,
all the drug dealers on the investigation.
But while I would watch all
these investigations like that,
you would see everything for what it
was and not for your perceptions because
you were there for so long.
So I would see the dealer sitting there,
but then I would see him
take care of his kid.
I would see him sit down and make food.
I would hear the other people in the
neighborhood talking about their lives and
hearing the smells of the hearing,
the sound, smelling the smells,
and realizing that this just wasn't a war.
This is ridiculous that we were
doing this. This was not the enemy.
This was a socioeconomic problem that
we had to deal with, but this isn't,
this isn't the enemy. We are not
at war. That's just preposterous.
So by being embedded in their community,
you recognize that we really are,
are you really were an occupying force
and just a a community that's trying to
get by and just a bunch of people
that are just like you or I,
but there are circumstances were
unfortunate. They were born into this,
this situation where this,
this cycle is perpetuated over and over
and over again and you've got a chance
to see it. All right,
let's not fool ourselves.
We want all won the lottery
here by being born in America.
We all won the lottery by being white.
So we have to recognize that angel
actually did go or if she's not, she's not
white. I checked in is plaque. I don't,
I get, I don't have an opinion of that. I
don't, sure. Don't send me to everybody.
Everybody should. Orange is the new
black. Right. Right. She's orange.
Ever look at her skin. You're
wrong. I'm not wrong. Look,
she did some good work too. She's a good,
uh, she was running the NAACP very well.
She's a great job.
She was there though.
She's got some issues she likes
black dudes at, she wanted to fit in.
There's a little farther
than that. Oh, a little bit.
Some people want to be checks. Some
people want to be black. Who gives a fuck?
Whether it be black. Sure.
She's helping. I got you.
A lot of people got mad at her
though. Yeah, I can imagine.
We're getting off track. It's all
right. Did other officers share your,
your, uh, I want to say like, I don't,
I don't want to say humanization,
but do your recognition of the fact
that these folks are just like you,
did other officers have that same feeling?
I think a lot of them do,
but it wasn't discussed. No. I mean you
don't discuss it while you're in. Uh,
except for maybe a few people.
When I was a sergeant, I had a,
a pretty good sphere of influence,
so our squad was a little more talkative
about things like that and could be
open and discuss those kinds of things.
Uh,
I took an officer once and just put
it on plain clothes and kind of walked
around the district just not being cops.
And that shows you like how much different
the neighborhood is then what you
think because you go from nine one
one call to nine, one one call,
it's nine one one call seen
everybody at their worst.
And when you're not seeing
them at their worst,
you're hunting for somebody that you can
possibly pretend that they're doing at
their worst, whether they have
drugs on them or or, or whatever.
But when you go through the city,
it's not at all what you think it is.
So even me looking like a prototypical
white kid looking to sell to buy drugs in
the, in the hood, when I
would go through the deal,
it's not like the dealers are pushers.
I mean, they would come up, Yo,
you want a party now and you keep on
moving. Sometimes they didn't trust me.
I was in too good a shape. They'd
be like, no. But they want like,
they were like pressuring you.
It's not like things were crayons and
neighborhood ladies were sweeping their
steps,
but the neighborhood changes when you
have that blue uniform in those lights and
your now the authority,
you kind of have to see the city for what
it's like when you're not there. Right.
So your point of view riding in a car,
it's like, yeah, there's a filter.
Super Myopic. Yeah. Yeah.
And you never really get a
chance to experience it like
a person who lives there.
I mean, even if you don't
really, if you don't live there,
but I mean just you get a better
view of it walking around and not,
not acting as a cop. Right. It's,
it seems common sense
that you would do that.
What would you think about cops being
forced to live in the places that they
have to patrol? I think as a trial,
that's a real tough situation.
It was a real tough argument
and very nuanced. Um, I would,
there's no way I would live in Baltimore
city because I didn't make enough money
for my daughter to go to a private
school and I wasn't sending her to that
school to prison cycle.
Right.
So I moved the PA where I could send her
to a good school and actually afford to
now sure if I made enough money.
If you're going to pay an officer
$150,000 slash $60,000, yeah,
he can stay in the city. He or
she can st city, but just say Pa,
you lived in Pennsylvania, right? So how
far away was that from where you were at?
40 minutes.
So you would live in Pennsylvania,
send your kid to school there and
then drive to work. Right. Fuck man.
And that's common.
So a lot of police live in,
in the southern Pa area,
driving back and forth in Maryland.
A lot of workers period do that.
There's a lot of communities around La,
like Simi Valley is a
big one where there's big
communities, a police officer's.
Is that the same thing with their,
where they just sort of decide live
near each other, close together.
But you don't do it intentionally? It's,
no, it's economically driven. Oh, okay.
So it's economically driven.
Like you find a place that's affordable,
but you don't, you don't, you don't try
to move where the other cops live. No, no,
I wouldn't want to do that. And
we worked with them all day. Well,
I know my friends that are cops,
they actually did it on purpose or some
that live in Santa Clarita or a little
deeper than they were pretty deep into
that then. Well, you know how it is.
It becomes like a gang,
right, isn't it? It is.
We actually say in the city that there
is one gang and that's the blue gangs.
So like we don't let people,
so aggression is good in a certain extent.
We don't let a gang members
throw flags like so in my post,
if somebody had a red Bandana, blue
Bandana, it's taken out of their pocket.
That shit was not going down. So you
arrested someone who wasn't wrestling?
I'm just pumpkin. Pumpkin. So,
so you're embarrassing me in front of
his friends who take his stuff and you
roll out. Did you ever
experience resistance? That's
sure they're going to resist.
If we're going to resist that
then it's going to go bad.
As long as at you or anything like that?
No, nothing. No, because it's the game.
So I'm respecting the game. You
know, there's a game, the drug game.
So I have my role,
the drug dealer has his role and we're
playing this back and forth and as long
as we all play by the rules,
everything is fine.
As soon as the cops stopped playing by
the rules of the game, then you a problem.
As soon as they stopped playing by the
rules of the game, you have a problem.
Does, did, did the futility of it all, was
that obvious to, yeah, incredibly obvious.
There's, there's no point. So we had a,
I remember a case we had where there was
a group that was selling drugs and we
worked on it for about a week or two,
took down the whole group and two days
later there was a whole new crew writing
the exact same neighborhood, throwing
the same product and we were just like,
fuck, that was pointless. We
just took the all them off.
There was no point to it whatsoever. And
it was all drugs anyway. It's all trucks.
Fucking, hey man, everything
is drugs. This, you know,
if I was a conspiracy theorist,
I kind of been one in the past,
but I've mostly abandoned that.
But if I was,
I would feel like this is engineered.
I'd feel like this is just set up to
make sure that these people stay poor,
that you keep arresting people and you,
you keep this cycle going.
I don't think you're a conspiracy
theorist, is that, I think you're right.
Is it because it exists and because the
system sort of feeds off of it or was it
engineered? I think the prison industrial
complex has a huge role in that.
So especially with your
privatizing prisons,
so you're creating a vacancy
for a bed that must be filled.
So who's going to fill that?
So this is where institutionally
racism also comes in.
I'm not going to fill it with you.
We're not going to fill it with me.
We're not gonna fit with Jamie.
Jamie's sketchy looking at him now we're
going to fill it with black people.
We like the least,
right?
As a society of people that you feel
like you can demonize the easiest.
When that judge got arrested in
Pennsylvania for sending kids to jail and
juvenile just for money,
we really got a view into this world
that I don't think would have a,
I think a lot of people that opened their
eyes, they went, Whoa, a fucking judge.
Judges can be that bad.
Judges can be so evil,
but they would ruin a child's life just
so that they could profit off of it.
But that's essentially what's going on by
keeping the system the way it is today.
The Baltimore police,
W who was he?
The head of Baltimore Police Commissioner
and Commissioner, he resigned,
or was he fired? He was
fired. He was fired.
And why was he fired because of all
this shit that's going down? Yeah,
it's a really hard situation
to say. I mean, he's,
he's fired because he never led the
agency. He's never had the agency ever.
We're really don't like outsiders.
So when he comes in here from Oakland,
from California, now,
if he came from Oakland,
Oakland's fucked up to Oakland is like
one of the worst police brutalities pots
and California. You find that
to be coincidental? That,
and there was an uprising in Oakland and
an uprising in Baltimore to agencies.
He led this motherfucker. What's
he doing now? Put Him in jail.
How about that cle lasts, you know, you
don't think it's gonna happen to you,
is it? No. No. Um, so what is his
name again? This guy, Anthony Batts.
And what did he do that was fucked up?
He just never had the agency.
So every never take,
you
can't.
So they come in and they come in with
these ideals of what it's like in
Baltimore and they don't know what it's
like in Baltimore because he knows what
it's like in Oakland. And
there's, hey Mel. I mean
hypothetically, barely. It barely,
it seems. Um, so they come in with
these, just these ideals and this,
uh, I don't know, aura and they're
never going to get us. Like,
they're never going to get us to follow
them. So it doesn't matter what he does,
we're not going to follow him.
He doesn't, he after the riots,
he said he should have trusted his
instincts and done more than 10 to rely on
his commanders.
Thank you.
You just threw your commanders under
the bus and public and you think this
agency is going to follow you.
What are you kidding me?
So he's a politician says they're all are.
That's one of our problems.
That's why we have to get money out
because we're led by politicians and
policing.
What could be done?
Like if you like let's say this
thing becomes bigger and look,
I think what you're doing today is very
courageous and you're speaking very
eloquently and very articulate
and you're honest and, and I,
I really believe you man.
I believe you from the heart 100%
there's a possibility that people like
you and all these activists that are,
they're making these giant protests
happen and causing all these people to be
aware of all this police brutality and
this fucking horrible cycle that these
people are or thrust into a guide.
Like you could really change something.
A guy like you,
if you were in a position of power there,
there might be something
that you could do.
Would you consider doing
something like that?
I would consider it if we
had the environment to do
so because it's going to be
ugly at first because I
can't stop the drug war. It's
not, it's not in my control.
Well, you shouldn't stop the drug
war. What? Like what? What if,
this is a big hypothetical,
but what if we went into some sort of
a situation that's competent in this
country were drugs became decriminalized,
where w the United States woke the fuck
up and realized we've been doing the
same shit that they did during the
fucking twenties during the, you know,
prohibition. We're doing
the same shit. We're,
we're telling people what they can't do.
They're not listening and
we're feeding organized crime.
We're feeding crime that is filling a
vacuum just like it's going on in Mexico
right now.
Just like these poor fucking people that
live in these border towns in Mexico.
The, it's all being fueled by the fact
that drugs are illegal and they're selling
these drugs to America.
If all of a sudden that changed,
how much of an impact
would that have on police?
It, it'd be striking, uh, that, that
again, that's 90% of what I did.
So if we would stop doing that,
it would be incredibly advantageous.
But what would they do with you
guys? See what I'm saying? Focus.
Let's investigate violence. Let's figure
out we're going to fix things. Okay,
so use some science to say,
we have a problem.
What do we do to actually
solve this problem?
Instead of being fueled by ideology?
What are we actually doing?
Well,
do you saw this recent thing on Obama's
gonna release all these nonviolent drug
offenders? I mean, that's a
good step. I concur completely.
That's a great step. Now,
if he does that,
and the next step is obviously
not arresting violent,
nonviolent drug offenders,
not arresting them at all.
Like there's no more arrest for drugs
unless there's violence involved.
And then you're arresting someone for
violence, which is totally reasonable.
It doesn't have,
it doesn't matter if they're violent over
fucking stuffed animals or cocaine who
gives a shit. They're violent,
right? They're hurting somebody.
That's why they're arrested. How much
would that transform neighborhoods?
How much would that transform this entire
cycle of people going from communities
that are just engulfed in crime and
becoming a part of that themselves because
they were unlucky enough to be born there?
I think it's the biggest
thing we could do as a nation.
I only put wolf pack and uh,
getting money out of politics ahead
of it because I questioned that we can
actually do that as money
continues to fuel the politician
and wolf pack is what's set up by
the young Turks. Right, right. Yeah.
Let's just fucking fantastic.
I love that.
There's another thing that my friend
Steve Hilton put together called Crowdpac
where you could see exactly which
politicians are being supported by,
by what, where they're getting
their donations from and just,
and what they vote on and get,
get a real clear analysis of
their position based on influence,
based on the amount of money they're
receiving and where it's coming from.
So it's all shocking shit because it's,
I just would hope that as we move
forward as a, as a human race,
as we move forward,
as a civilization moves forward and we
embrace technology and we understand that
we have more access to information now
than any human beings that have ever
lived ever to keep living the same way.
Even though we have all these obvious
problems right in front of us is
ridiculous. I mean it's literally
the definition of insanity,
doing the same thing over and over
again hoping for a different result.
And that is the definition of insanity.
Right?
Totally agree. There's this, there's no
way around it that we're doing this wrong.
And that's why I'm saying the only
reason I'm saying this is because we are
doing it so wrong and it's
so blatantly wrong. It's,
it's like you have to have a cognitive
bias to not see this. Like how,
how the,
it's really the older generation.
I kind of pretty much confidence that
our generations and younger will be able
to solve this and once we get in power,
but how they don't see this now is
absolutely baffling. And I don't,
I think they don't see it
because it doesn't affect them.
So why should they care?
Were you
still on the force where the,
when that guy got choked
to death and Staten Island?
I don't think I was when I was
Eric Gardner. Yeah, Eric Gardener.
That one drove me fucking crazy because
there's a video it and you get to see
the fact that this guy was so innocent.
There's nothing wrong
with what he was doing.
And he's just hanging out tax
evasion. Tax evasion. Exactly.
But the idea that these cops are gonna
choke to death because he's not paying
taxes on loose cigarettes.
Not only that,
he didn't even have any loose cigarettes
on them and they wrestled in the ground,
choked him, and then tried to
say that it wasn't a choke hold.
I mean that one just highlights
the difference between
the way they treated that
guy versus the way they would treat
one of their own versus it's a clear us
versus them. And they felt like they could
do that. They could do that. They had,
the papers were signed,
they had the directive.
It was obvious that it was within their
boundaries to take this guy and to
physically assault him and arrest him.
And so they don't have empathy.
So if you wanted to see them,
empathy, police, we need to be moral.
We need to be human.
That's what I'm [inaudible] my main
message is we have to lead with empathy.
That's the starting point of everything.
So if I'm going after that guy,
I can immediately see that brother,
there's a law or not.
The idea that I'm going to
take someone's freedom away,
like they took his life away,
but they were planning to take his
freedom away for essentially nothing in
stupid tax.
That's a penny's that he's
providing a service to somebody.
If you don't have five bucks
and you want a cigarette,
that guy's a providing a
service. So why don't you, uh,
let him set up a little booth
and he can take not only that,
didn't he paid taxes on those
fucking stats? So what? Jesus Christ,
I mean, you know, he's making a little bit
of a profit, but who gives a shit? Her?
No one's getting hurt
and no one literally,
no one's getting hurt and the money
that they could have made just by
eliminating the drug war in taxes would
make that look like a pittance. It just,
the amount of taxes they're getting from
Colorado, Colorado is fucking changed.
I mean, it is morphing right in front of
our eyes and becoming this free utopia.
Yeah, you got a lot of dirty hippies there
and a lot of fucking homeless people,
but that's part of the route you're going
to get that they don't bother anybody.
I mean, they might bother you a little
bit, but whatever. Yeah. Who gives a shit?
I mean that's,
that's why don't conservative see this.
Why don't these days
they live in the suburbs then my
neighbors, they want money. I mean,
that money's going to go
to their schools as well.
That's going to make it safer for their
kid to go to 4th of July in the city
that's going to make
it safer for all of us.
The answer is blatantly obvious that we
must end the war on drugs and we must
get money out of politics. But we just
sit here with are sitting on our hands.
Well,
I agree with you,
but I think you having these kinds of
conversations live online in a forum like
this where it's going to be
distributed to millions of people.
You have the opportunity to influence
people that might not see things your way
because you have a genuine insight in a,
in a,
in a real perspective
that very few people,
including me could ever hope to have you
saying this kind of stuff and you talk
about this kind of stuff can shed some
light in a way that other people can.
I'm listening to you
talk here, man. I'm like,
you're the fucking perfect commissioner.
You're the,
you're the kind of guy that I would
want running a police department. You,
you're a guy who's been there,
a guy who's served the country,
been there as a cop,
understands what the problems are and,
and has solutions and has
empathy and really is,
you're saying all the right shit.
I mean, this is what we need.
This is what the police of the departments
of the world of this country at least
need.
We need someone like you.
So how do I convince other cops of
that? That's, that's my struggle.
I don't know man. I mean, I know a lot
of cops listen to the fucking podcast.
I'll tell you that I, I mean, I dunno
if this is going to change them,
but they're going to fucking Joe Rogan's
hi. Listen in on the streets with us,
dude. But you know, you've seen the
blue, the blue light sticker, right? Yes.
The black on the top,
black on the bottom.
So we even visualize
ourselves the wrong way.
So we're this thin blue line and the
thin blue line goes to the middle and it
separates the good guys from the bad guys.
And it makes us neither.
Our entire mentality is that we
are somebody that's separate.
We're not the good guys or the bad guys.
We're a separate entity that,
that runs this shit and, but
that, that shouldn't be that way.
There should be like a
blurred blue and black.
We should be part of the fabric
of our society and we should,
we should be ingrained in it.
But instead we Fitch
ourselves like a wall.
And we shouldn't be a wall.
I think human beings inherently
have a problem with power. You know?
That's why you see,
I mean,
you see it across the board when people
have power and influence over people
alike, it seems to be a natural
inclination to abuse it.
And it takes someone a very strong
character and insight and objectivity like
yourself to not do that.
Or at least to recognize that you have
done that and that it is wrong or that it
was wrong.
It seems to me that like whether it's
politicians or whether it's the military
or whether it's, what are some of the
like fucking Bill Cosby, you know,
like how does a guy become that guy?
Well, I eat has to be out of power,
you know?
I mean it's the power even even just
might be a stretch, but the
power to drug someone, the,
the ability to do that and yeah,
if it's like how, what it is,
what is it about human beings that that
makes them exploiting people that are
below them instead of trying to
raise those people up to their level.
There's some fundamental lack of
understanding about the brotherhood and
sisterhood of the human race that gets,
it all gets fucked up when you have a job.
And it seems to me that if you have
a quota and if you have a boss that's
telling you you need to arrest more
people, you need to lock up more people.
Like these streets are too safe.
You're either,
either you're doing the right
thing or you're not doing enough.
And they almost always think
not doing enough. Right.
They never would think,
oh,
this guy got lucky and he created a good
relationship with all these people and
we locked up all the bad guys and all
the people in the community that are left
are all safe.
There's no more violent criminals.
It's a beautiful utopia of a neighborhood.
And we never,
never have to arrest anybody there ever
again. So cops would just be there,
just sorta say hi and patrol the streets.
Yeah,
that sounds like a great idea. And, but
you see it, you see that. So you see it.
So the first step is to recognize it.
It's so do we have a problem with power
we have as human beings? Maybe we do.
So let's acknowledge that and put measures
in place so that we don't exceed our
power boundaries have some checks and
balances in law enforcement because we
have zero.
We did away with everything we want to
get away with until there's a camera.
The only difference, all these other
things that you've seen in the past.
You've heard these stories
of guys getting shot unarmed,
but yet he was attacking my
gun or he was taking my gun.
How much do you really believe those now?
Well we saw that the one where the guy
in South Carolina shot the guy in the
back and then drop the Taser,
walked up to him and through
the Taser down near his body.
I mean there's drops anything.
There's a video of it.
I don't know if the other cops
saw it. I don't know. I'll do it.
It's right in front of them.
You saw them doing nothing of it cause
it's video cause it's normal. It's normal.
We're not the only saw.
The one guy is the other guy in the video.
The other guys see the Taser cause
it's obvious that he sees it.
I mean he's the first stand right next
to him on he, I don't, I don't know.
But the fact that he shot him in
the back while I was running away,
I mean that's kind of fucking crazy.
It's crazy.
Is that guys being charged for
murder, right? Yeah. Well that's nice.
But it's because anybody, right?
Nobody ride it there. Why?
Because they don't get all, they're
all booked. All of the uprising.
Deray was booked things.
What happened with Deray?
You got them to not this guy,
deray is a,
a really noble activist and I appreciate
everything this guy is doing and I
appreciated him, uh, making Wolf
Blitzer look like a fucking idiot on TV.
But uh, he had me blocked for some
reason, but you got them to unblock me.
I got them to unblock you. What?
I think it's totally conjecture,
but I think he's just leery of us. And
I understand that white people, us,
we're in the same group. Yeah,
I think so. And He's white.
He blocked me because I'm white.
That that has something to do. No,
his blocking has something to do with
something. He thought that you said.
What do you think? I said, I don't
remember. But how can you remember that?
Now you're gonna have to talk to him.
Okay. You can't say it. No, I mean,
I just don't know enough and I didn't
dig. It was just not my business. Okay.
So he thought I said something racist.
I don't know what he thought he said.
He said he thought you said something
that he didn't, you didn't like.
And I just said, you know,
trust me, he's fine. He's,
he's, he's one of the good guys.
Don't worry about it. Okay. Maybe I said
a joke. Even my said something off color.
It's always hard with being a comedian,
man.
Maybe heard me talk about Trans
racialism and how I support it.
I think he's probably a little brief
on that. And so like, should be,
but why not? Fuck it. He's a
good guy and I hope things,
but I know his lack of trust.
Well, I understand. I guess. Um,
but I understand not, not, I don't
understand this lack of trust in me.
I just don't understand
that I'm so trustworthy,
but I understand what he's doing
and I think it's spectacular.
He to me is a real activist as opposed
to Al Sharpton who just makes my fucking
blood curdle.
When I see that guy show up at any
fucking event that has anything to do with
black people at was Jesus fucking Christ.
Like I got this more
harm than he does good.
Just by his just greasy past
is history and they just,
there's so much about him that's just so
wrong and it's nice to see someone like
deray come along.
It's nice to see a real activist.
Someone who is intelligent,
is articulate,
is doing all the right things and
I think between a guy like that,
but trying to,
between many people I can,
I'm sure there's a lot more people
like him that I'm not aware of.
And then someone like you who shedding
light on this from the inside.
I think things are slowly
but surely turning.
I think the battleship is moving in
a different direction. I really do.
I really think the whole country
is moving in a different direction.
And I think that when we see the way
people are approaching gay rights now,
the way this,
the way the world is just
more sensitive about things.
And some people are angry at it as
saying everyone's over-sensitive.
I think it's probably better to be over
sensitive than it to be insensitive
cause over sensitive can be
corrected. And people were like, well,
the people who are,
you know,
there's lives are being ruined because
people were being over sensitive.
You know, there was a Nobel prize
winning doctor or a professor that,
um,
made a joke about women in science and
he said they should probably have a same
sex labs because, uh, three things
happen when women are in the labs.
He said,
either they fall in love with you or you
fall in love with them or they cry when
you criticize them.
And he was joking around against
allegedly and he had to resign.
He had to resign for that, for
something like that. You know,
they say equality and science
is more important like that,
that mother curing cancer.
All right,
this guy's a Nobel prize winning scientist
and he says something that's a little
goofy but it doesn't have
some history of oppression.
He's not some terrible person is.
It's this massive over sensitivity
by people where you can't even just,
you know, say that's probably not a
good thing to say. And He, you know,
can kind of correct it and you can kind
of smooth it out cause you understand
the people talk off the top of their head.
This is not like a fucking story wrote
for the New York Times where he made it
had a clear position on women in science
and it became a real issue because he
criticized people that might have gotten
into science and done some real good
work. Now this guy, the
guy's just talking, you know,
and I think symptoms like that,
like the,
these issues that we face,
it's way better to have the APP
than it is to have insensitivity.
I think the over sensitive
things like that, it's, it
sucks at this guy got fired,
but, or that he resigned but he shouldn't
have. And I buy, I blame the institution.
I blamed the people running for that,
that are so fucking sensitive that they,
they, and, and so terrified that they're
worried about any criticism whatsoever,
that they reacted to it
and this way and him,
he shouldn't have fucking
back down from it.
Either he's going to talked about it
and explained or maybe an apologize.
Maybe you even said it was an
off color joke or it was just,
I just think that that balance is,
is because we're moving in the right
direction. I really do. I think I,
even though I've been a victim of over
sensitivity, um, I shouldn't say victim.
That's sounds very
grandiose. I, it's, it's,
it's affected me or it's impacted me
or I've felt it. I've seen it rather,
I think it's better.
It's better to have all those fucking
crazy people running around looking at
things to be offended about looking at a,
you know,
examples of sexism or
homophobia or racism. It's,
it's better to have people reaching
too far than to not reach it all.
And I think because we're
seeing all this stuff,
I think it's evidence that
society as a whole than our,
our culture in America is
tipping towards being more aware.
And I think that's a good thing. I really
do. Um, I have a lot of hope, you know,
a lot of people think that I'm like,
well,
overly optimistic about the future of
this country and the human beings in
general.
But I'd see plenty of evidence that people
are aware and that they care and just
all the people that are paying attention
to your story and all these different
protests and marches and all these
different news stories when any,
whenever we see these examples
of police brutality, it's,
there's so highlighted now,
this is not swept under the rug at all.
And if anything, the cops are fucking
thrown under the bus immediately. I mean,
is it,
it's a different world and I think
there's going to be an adjustment period.
But I think ultimately when
we look back at this time,
10 20 years from now, I think we're
going to look at this as a shift,
as a shift in our culture that we
didn't see in the 60s you know, there's,
when I think when the,
when Martin Luther King was
around and when there was a shift,
then there was most certainly a, an a,
an awareness, a civil rights awareness.
But I think it's even bigger now.
I really do.
I think this is a great
time to be a human being.
I really think that we have the real
potential to make some real change inside
our lifetime and change that
can give momentum to the future.
I think there's, without question
that you're completely right,
they can't avoid it. I mean we're, we're,
technology has made us communicate.
We see everything.
We can't hide as much anymore.
We just have to be human and recognize
all of our flaws and everything will be
fine with your doctor.
If we could have some empathy for his
position because empathy a two way street,
then maybe you can work out a solution
for understanding and that ball game and
that's what we're doing now is where
we're working out the understanding and
it's going to have this ugly
period in policing for sure,
but we'll get through it and it's
going to be better. It's inevitable.
I don't think it's me. It's going
to be somebody that comes behind me,
but it's going to,
it's going to work
well. Yeah, I think you're a part of
it. Uh, I think we're all a part of it.
I think someone like you is uniquely
qualified to be a part of it. You know,
the fact that you actually,
or they're on the street arresting
dude is wearing somebody else's pants.
I think it just shows you're uniquely
qualified to talk about this.
And I think that there's a real potential
with this kind of dialogue and with
people just being more and more aware of
it that a young kid that might be like
1617 years old right now that is about
to go into the marines and has the same
idea that you had.
He has a leg up.
Maybe he can learn from your experiences
and maybe his comrades and maybe his,
his peers can also learn from what you're
saying and your experiences and maybe
someone like you one day
becomes a commissioner and
maybe that time while that's
happening that that one
commissioner starts listening
to good politicians and it
gets influenced by good
leaders and doesn't have to
start arresting people just
for drugs,
doesn't have to PR just perpetrate this
same stupid fucking cycle that's been
going on and on.
I mean is that too much to ask?
Is that too unrealistic to
hope that we can change things?
I mean you can't,
you can't think that we're not going
to improve if we're not going to,
we're going to stay stagnant as a
culture. Well that's, that's ridiculous.
That's shitty engineering.
That's non non thinking.
That's are you always
saying that we're perfect?
Are we saying that it's few tile?
Are we saying that it can't be fixed or
are we saying that we're not willing to
try?
One of the one of those is happening.
The majority is not willing
to try but you even,
I don't think I belong on the pedestal.
You're put me on maybe somebody else wants
because I participated in all of this.
Maybe we can have people that go on.
It's on a pedestal. I'm not putting you
on a pedestal. I'm just saying your, your,
your, your hope, what
you're doing. This is hope.
You
influenced that though with this.
Okay,
so you have this philosophy where you
were like it doesn't matter what you do,
just fucking be nice. Just be nice and
listening to youth through these years,
that has invaded my mind as well.
So if we can just talk and start
opening up as humans and be nice and be
empathetic, then we're going to work
that all of this out regardless.
Bernie Sanders might even
be a good example of that
with his message right now.
Huge following. Right. And
like vote for this guy. Yeah.
I mean we're going to make changes.
It's like if you're a progressive
then you want to make changes.
If you're a conservative,
you want to stay in the past.
This is what these words mean.
It doesn't make any sense.
Who would want to be conservative
and stuck in the past?
The only person is going to be stuck in
a past is one with the confederate flag
that's collecting money off
the backs of somebody else.
Well this a definition of conservative,
I think it's all fucked up.
Now conservative should be someone
who's fiscally conservative.
That and then the,
which is someone who's prudent,
someone it makes good financial choices.
That's a good thing.
That's a smart thing.
It's someone with discipline that's,
I support that 100% you know,
good financial decisions or
that is a conservative thing.
You know when you start getting socially
conservative that means you're white.
That's what it means. You might as
well say you're white, you know,
or you're a black guy.
He likes hanging out with white people
and being paid more than he's worth.
Cause you know, that's
what happens. I mean it's,
we live in a weird world right now and
I think society is being redefined right
in front of our eyes.
I think when we look back at this time,
a hundred years from now,
when people look back when we're dead,
they're going to look back and go,
guys, a fucking crazy time to be alive.
That Internet just fucking threw a
monkey wrench into the whole gears.
Kaklink you know, I mean that's
really what's happening. The, this,
this ability to communicate just didn't
exist before you being able to come on a
show like this. This is never, this wasn't
supposed to happen. No, not at all. If we,
if this show was on the
radio or something like that,
first of all we'd be interrupted by
commercials and then second of all,
someone will probably tell us we can't
talk about these things or we can't talk
about like the way we're talking.
You can't swear.
We had already been arrested for swearing.
You can get a fucking fine,
have some insane amount.
I think it's like $250,000 for
swearing on the radio for swearing.
Like just saying,
get the fuck outta here on the radio.
You can go to jail if you don't pay that,
fine.
If you don't pay that
quarter million dollar fine.
The vig to the government that they,
that's where Howard stern came in. Man,
Howard stern fought all that shit.
That's why that guy is always
going to be a hero to me.
I don't give a fuck what he says about
podcasting or Ari should fear already
that crazy shit that
it wasn't for that guy.
That guy fought the fight
and the powers that be,
that have set this stupid thing up.
They didn't anticipate that a guy like
you would be able to go on the young
Turks later this afternoon
and say anything you want man,
and that young Turks thing will be
seen by fucking million people. Easy.
And that's, that's hope, man. That's hope.
Because what we're talking about where
you listen to some of the things that
I've said, those things that I've said
I've heard online, you know I've read,
I've watched documentaries, I've, I've,
I'm expressing things that I've learned
and we all learn from each other and we,
all the community that we create by
finding likeminded people or by saying
things that resonate with people or by
influencing people in a positive way
where it actually helps their mindset
and helps their life and they become
thankful of that.
And then they spread the same kind of
message and we help spread it to each
other. And I could have a guy like you
want and you change the way I think about
certain things and you influence.
Like I'm,
I'm genuinely honored to have
you on the show. I'm genuinely,
I really admire what you've
done and what you're saying.
And I think other people will as well.
And I think it spreads,
it's like a good virus.
Like it gets out there and this,
this wasn't available before.
Something like this wasn't available.
And I think that's part of why we all
got locked into this US versus them
mentality.
We didn't have a voice that distinguishes
or differentiates from the fucking
same bullshit corporate voice that we
keep hearing over and over and over again.
That doesn't differentiate. You
don't hear any, you don't hear any.
We are all brothers and sisters
on Fox News. You don't hear that.
What do you hear? You hear
crimes, statistics. You know,
you hear Nancy grace with two
Chainz debating about marijuana.
I mean he really, that's what you
hear. You hear bullshit nonsense.
You don't hear any soul. You know,
no one's got a goddamn heart, no one,
no one recognizes the fact that
this is a temporary existence.
We're going through a temporary
existence and there are so many of us and
there's pockets that seem
almost unmanageable because
they've been fucked over
for hundreds of years and there's just
a swarming chaos in these areas and they
just, they're riding a
momentum and they're riding on
the momentum of decades and
decades of poverty and crime and a cycle
of despair and is going to be hard to
fix that shit.
But it's critical and it's one of the most
important aspects of our civilization.
If we don't fix that,
our civilization is nonsense.
Our civilization is only as
strong as the weakest links.
And it just makes sense to me.
And I've always said this,
the best way to strengthen America. People
want to talk about a strong America.
Are you a patriot? Do you love
America? Good, less losers,
make less losers.
Then you have a stronger America.
Go to the fucking
neighborhoods that are fucked.
Go to the communities that are fucked.
Go to these deeply entrenched
in crime areas and fix them.
You fix them.
Then you got winners.
You got instead of 10,000 people in jail,
he got 10,000 people that are
starting small businesses.
You've got 10,000 people
that are venturing out into
the world and trying to do
good and influencing other people to
do the same and spreading a positive
message and and influencing people
with inspiration. And then they,
the other people see, hey this guy
became this. I can do this too.
And then they do it too.
And then other people say that.
And you've got a better country.
It's, it's not that hard.
Instead of being a fucking vampire and
arresting people for crack and pulling
people over and doing the same goddamn
shit that everybody's been doing for the
last hundred years,
it's striking how much
we do things similar.
One of the things we found when we were
messing around digging through files is
we found a,
an action plan a and these action plans
like so a big crime happens and you,
you're the shift commander were
drop an action plan and send it up.
What he's going to do to address this and
this action plan was from the 1970s we
found it in like 2010 whoa.
And you found it.
We found it in a drawer and it was the
exact same action plan as the other shift
commander was doing. It was
like the same, the same corners,
the same response, the same
plan. So like for 40 years,
nobody's changed anything and you have
the same corners being the same problems
with the same families and the doing
the same things and the police are doing
the exact same goddamn thing
in response. Wow. It's,
it's unbelievable how we're doing this.
And that's what these talks have to get
us to do is to do exactly what you're
saying. Communicate, lift up the country.
It doesn't make any sense that we would
treat a medical problem like it's a
criminal problem and put those people
into a jail to drug addicts into,
into a jail cell. It doesn't
make any sense. I'm sorry. What?
What happens to the cop on the
beat right now in Baltimore?
What happens to the cops that
are listening to this right now?
What the fuck can they do?
These guys have an incredibly hard time
right now because like you're saying
with bats,
he's not leading the agency properly.
The FOP is doing some
crazy things as well, uh,
to calling the uprising lynch mobs,
going after the wanting to send their
officers down the pike and doing all these
things when we need justice.
We need something.
The case needs to be heard in court for
anybody to have any assemblance that
this is going to be real.
And this is going to be just because in
the past we know it's all been covered
up.
So if we continue to cover up,
which is the problem that happened
in Ferguson is the cover up.
The problem isn't the shooting problem
is that damn cover up that prosecutors a
criminal, he criminally covered up that
indictment. There's no way around it.
That's what they did and no one seemed to
care. So what did he do? Highlight what?
What happened?
So when you have an indictment,
the old saying is as you can indict
a ham cheese sandwich because the,
the prosecutor goes up there and
his job or her job is to select the,
the evidence that will get the charge.
So the way that system
actually is is if there's,
there's four of us in the room right now.
If three of us think he
did it and one doesn't,
we don't even listen to the one that
does it. That's how an indictment works.
If you're not relying to witness,
you don't even come in for the indictment.
But in that case,
he brought in unreliable witnesses,
brought in everybody to taint the whole
thing when all he should have brought in
was the case that,
okay,
so this guy was shot and he was found
this way and these witnesses say that he
put his hands up and you would have had
an indictment and you would have had a
trial and you would've, he would've,
I think that shooting was justified.
So Darren Wilson would
have been exonerated and
everything would've been fine,
but we would at least heard the case.
The problem is,
is that the police walk away with nothing,
so it's like you shoot him,
oh no, we're not going to indict
it. Okay, see you later. Good luck.
Looks like everything was clear.
Well, we need to see more than that.
That's why when you see the indictments,
South Carolina, there was no uprising. We,
we had a shooting in Baltimore just not
too long ago where a guy was robbing a
seven 11 I think in the
officer came in and shot them.
There's some speculation that
the guy wasn't even armed,
but he was robbing a store
so nobody freaks out.
The problem is is when you
have somebody on our end,
but no clear crime and it's
just, okay, that's what happened.
He was afraid what fear is not enough
justification to shoot somebody.
But that's what the law says.
The law says that if you're in
fear of your life as an officer,
you can pull that trigger.
That's preposterous.
You have to at least be some assemblance
of containing your situation and not
just being what it is now as
they're afraid at everything.
So everybody has a gun,
which you know that's an American problem,
but they feel like everybody is a threat
and you're ingrained into this threat.
So they run around with fear and they
have your shoot in a heartbeat because
they're so afraid.
And then the scene,
they just come behind and they cover it
all up like nothing happened and that's
when you get an uprising.
It's just when there is no justice.
That's what Marilyn Mosby
did, you know, like okay. Did.
Was there uprisings after
she came out and said, okay,
we're going to charge the officer's?
No,
because it's not that
everybody's rushing to judgment.
It's not that it's a lynch mob.
It's let this play out in court.
I think the two lower
officers are going to get off.
I don't think that they did
anything particularly wrong.
They were following their lieutenant.
They might have some things.
They might not be cops, but they
didn't do anything terribly wrong.
But you want to hear the case and
you want to know what happened.
We have to know what happened.
Just because a guy has a gun and we give
them a badge and he has a GED and he
went to eight months of training.
Doesn't make him above the world.
It doesn't make him a
separate set of rules.
What you think that the
Ferguson shooting was justified?
I can't go far as to say it's justified.
I think the evidence would say that it,
it would be rule justified.
I don't know why.
Because he struck the officer and he is
a close range and it seems like he was
trying to get his gun. Yeah. If,
I mean in that situation I think you
get the benefit of doubt to the officer.
But why were there so many
people that disagreed?
What was the hands up and all
that stuff? Right. Who knows?
Did he have his hands
up? Was that, who knows?
But I think that's enough
justification to find that out. Right.
And how would they find that out?
At least have the witnesses on Stan.
But it would just be
questioning witnesses.
It would just be I witness information.
Sure, sure. But let's hear it. You know,
maybe he gets out, but it's exonerated
and everything's fine, but let's hear it.
We need to,
here we have,
we know that we have a history of
officer's unjustly shooting black males,
especially on armed.
We know we have that so that that means
we must have an extra level of scrutiny.
We have to, and what is the
situation in Cleveland with the kid?
A 12 year old kid that had the,
that was at the school yard there.
That guy's being indicted
on murder charges. Right.
Last I knew he wasn't that
judge suggested that he,
there was a judge that said there was
enough probable cause to warrant the
charging, but somebody else
actually has to do that charging.
I don't believe that's taken place so
that one doesn't make any fucking sense at
all. Fucking murder is a
murder. It's absolute. There's
no justification for that.
There's not been a single thing I've
ever watched that that affected me more
than watching those fucking cops murder
Tamir rice and then stand over that boy,
a 12 year old boy as he was bleeding out
and choking, they stood there and they,
he's worried conjecture, but it
looks like he's worried. Oh my God,
I'm in this situation.
What am I going to do as a 12 year old
boy fucking chokes on his own blood dying
and he stands there,
stands there doing nothing until someone
else comes over and finally helps that
boy and he's not being indicted.
Are we kidding me?
That's fucking murder and
shot him within two seconds.
It was lesson 1.6 seconds.
They rush up on that kid.
There's no justification for any of them.
What's happening in Cleveland is absurd.
There's no doubt about,
is Cleveland like Baltimore
at the same sort of cycle?
I have no reason to believe that
Cleveland, Baltimore, Ferguson, Atlanta,
any of those places are different.
I think we can take an officer.
There's some just happened in Philly
just now before I walked in here.
A video was released of Philly officer's
a 12 Philly officers beating on
somebody that was on armed for apparently
riding a bike or something like that.
I have no,
I didn't get a chance to see.
But all of these things
seem to be the same.
So if you took an officer out of Philly,
you can put them in Baltimore. He's fine.
When we had Hurricane
Katrina, we took, uh,
maybe 20 officers from New Orleans and
brought them into the BPD and they,
there's not like, they like, oh my God,
what are we doing? It was the same.
Same thing. Same Shit, same shit.
Different report. That's all.
So it's just ghettos.
Ghettos. Yes. A black guy goes to a
separate, a separate level. Black ghettos,
mostly black, low income period. It's
the power list, the voiceless period.
But I think that institutional racism
that we have throughout our society,
it wasn't that long ago that we're having
slaves and were still arguing over the
confederate flag.
I know you said something about they're
arguing about the dukes of Hazzard.
I think you confused sir.
Yeah, they're fucking,
how about the fact that it flies over
state house until 2015 it's God damn
crazy.
Yeah.
The fact that this is the first year that
someone stepped up and stop that from
happening and then
people are freaking out.
It's about heritage southern narrative.
Imagine,
imagine a Nazi flag Nazi flag
flying up. I mean, oh, come on.
What did you say though about that
flag? Come on. I saw you say something.
What was it? Oh, I said about daisy
Duke. I said the real flag was the,
the daisy dukes. The shorts, because
that was a flag of empowerment.
There's it never been.
It was an article of clothing.
Well for females and for gay
men, sluts and gay men. That's,
there was never an article
of clothing that's,
that just clearly outlined
that you're hungry for Dick.
There was one that we've ever created
and that's the daisy Duke shorts.
Nobody wears daisy Duke
shorts if you don't want Dick,
if you're a dude and you were in daisy
Duke shorts hunting for Dick and if your
girl,
we're in daisy Duke shorts,
you're hunting for deck and there
was never like a flag. They like,
they threw up a flag that let up,
let people know they want some deck and
I have an objection. It's true, right?
It's true. That's the, that's
the real fucking travesty.
What they should do is go
over that fucking show, put
the show back on the air.
God dammit,
go over that show at some CGI.
Put a Goddamn American flag on the roof
and let's be done with it. How long,
how much would that cost?
They could do that shit if they could
make the Hawk and the Avengers bounced
through buildings and
shit. You told me. Yeah.
You can't fucking fake a flag
on the roof of up. First of all,
the real crime is to paint that fucking
beautiful car, that shitty color.
You took us 69 charger or a 68 charger,
whichever one wants to think is this nine
one of the most beautiful muscle cars
ever created. And you painted it
like you goddamn Spanish hooker.
The bullshit. That's the real
bullshit. Paint that fucking thing.
Orange was stupid flag of a bunch of
losers. That's a loser flag by the way.
Yeah, you heard me folks,
y'all lost treasonous assholes.
It's like raising a flag or
another country anyway, did well,
it's like raising a foe.
They wanted to win and they
didn't win was about economics.
It's about economics. Yeah. If you
don't pay people, you make more money.
So that's an economic choice.
You know,
the south represents and
that flag represented a lot
of things to people other
than racism.
What they need is a new flag.
You need a new flag that represents the
south alone and not a bunch of people
that were fighting to keep racism.
You know, Dan Carlin said that, um,
they should add to the flag,
like maybe keep that flag and put a
broken chain on it that represents the,
the abolishment of slavery that like,
it keeps southern heritage within an ads.
One thing to it, I mean,
that might be a thing,
but they could come up with
another fucking flag. It's
a flag. It's just a symbol.
If you want a symbol of the South
Texas has a fucking beautiful flag.
Texas has a flag and the star of Texas
and nobody ever thinks of it representing
racism or represent, it's just
fucking Texas. The Star of Texas.
It's just the star of Texas that's legit.
Like if you were a Texas flag t
shirt on, everybody knows. Wow.
That's the guy who was a fan of Texas.
You know what I'm saying?
It doesn't have any connotation that you
hate black people or you want racism or
you want slavery. That's
a, that's a legit flag.
They need to come up with a goddamn
better flag up for world with no flags.
A world with no flags. Mm hmm. Okay.
What about the don't tread on me.
That's pretty slick. I like that
one snake. Oh No, no. Nobody say,
I mean everybody has had it. Don't try
it on the side, but you really have,
are they scared of those people?
How about an eagle?
Probably either the fucking talent,
fuller rockets,
rockets and one and then
the other one a dick.
He's got a dick in one hand.
Represent everybody just talking shit.
I just think that uh, yeah, the
world, a world without flags,
like ideally no ideology,
you know, ideally no, uh,
no borders.
Ideally no nationalism,
no state pride and just be proud that
you're a human being and human race.
But there's some cool shit
about having differences.
There's some cool shit that you can go
to New Mexico and it's different than
going to Michigan. I liked
that. I liked variation.
I like people that are happy
that they live in Los Angeles.
They have pride
straightening your nice here.
Yeah, I like it. I never been to the
west coast. We were just driving around.
We went up the Pacific coast today,
coastal highway today, and uh, the canyon,
I can't remember his,
call it Malibu Canyon.
Beautiful one of my bikes so bad I was
hurting. It's like, where can I rent them?
Motorcycle. Malibu Canyon road is
amazing and it was unbelievable what?
We've never seen anything like that.
But in the northeast we have water.
Oh yeah, yeah. We'll
still water from Seattle.
They ain't gonna do shit about it
either. Stop, take that water, son.
Give me that shit.
This is what I think.
If they could bring fucking oil down
from Alaska, why can't they bring water?
They can hook a big tube up to one of
those melting glaciers and you steal all
that fucking water and we're good.
And then we irrigate the shit out of
this bitch and turn into a tropical rain
forest. Just giant sprinklers
that are in the sky. You know,
giant ones like 30,000 feet up,
just spraying shit. Come on,
man. You can make a hyperloop. They can
get to San Francisco in five seconds.
Like what Elon Musk is trying to do. You
can't put a sprinkler system in the sky.
I think you can't steal water out of the
icebergs that everybody's worried about.
Global warming with the iceberg smelt.
The Malibu is going to disappear.
Fuck it is.
We're going to put a big goddamn too
and suck all those icebergs.
It's sprayed all over the avocado fields.
That sounds crazy to watch up either
solution. It is a solution. It's why not.
If you can get oil from Saudi Arabia
by millions and millions of gallons and
tankers and bring it across
the god Damn Ocean to America,
you're telling me you can't take water
from somewhere and bring it down here.
That's stupid.
Of course they can.
The problem is can they get enough water?
Cause we use a lot of fucking water.
There's a lot of golf courses here.
People like to call off a lot of
white people and there's almonds.
Almonds apparently suck up a lot of
water and a lot of people have pools.
There's a lot of issues,
but I think they can be engineered.
You know the real issue is,
you know,
there's a lot of global warming talk,
but I think Pete places have
always turned, you know,
there's always been like air.
I mean,
all you have to do is just look back
to the ice age and you realize, well,
there's not an ice age anymore, so
something happened. There's some change.
Well that's this. We don't live in this
static place, but we're so arrogant.
We figured out, we feel like if we
build a city, we could stay. You know,
this is it. We're here now.
But if this becomes a Sahara,
you know there's a go to this
hair does it? What do you find?
You don't find a lot of fucking people.
There's a reason. There's nothing there.
You can't live off of it. What do
you, what are you going to eat, man?
You can eat your camel if you don't eat
your camera. There's not a lot to eat,
you know? And that's just the
reality of being a human being.
If we live on this earth,
we occasionally you have to move
because the spots socks. Now, you know,
this spot is fantastic.
You're this, you're here for
the first time. But listen,
there's a reason why there's 30 million
fucking people stuffed into this area.
It's because it's a sweet spot.
But all it take is one of those,
the, the rock style earthquakes
from that new fucking movie.
One real one,
which has happened before.
They've had some giant ones in spots
all over the world that we know of.
You know,
that human beings don't have record of
that had just been just unbelievably
devastating.
All we'd need is one of those just one.
And everybody would scatter like ants.
And then you go to boulder, Colorado,
be over one with chicks from Santa Monica.
It'd be dudes on Adderall
with fucking botox faces
driving the Tesla's around boulder. Hey,
that's, it's become, it's a nice car.
It's fast too. It's a good car.
Beautiful. Um, but you guys,
it's too cold in Baltimore. That's
bullshit. Yeah. We had a bad winter.
It's nothing. I grew up in Boston, which
is worse, way worse through though.
Uh, how that city, uh, it's all right.
It's okay. You can fucking have it
for five months. A year and a yes,
that's right when summer time.
So I'm still talking about my house at
a bit summertime in Boston's amazing.
It's like I'm, I'm going to Chicago, uh,
at the end of the month and I'm fucking
site because Chicago in the summer is
amazing.
You know why?
Because those people appreciate
the fact that it's the summer,
summer in la every day.
It could be 90 in January here.
I mean it's happened many times,
right? Jamie? You experienced 90? Yeah.
Walking around in shorts. Flip
flops. Tee Shirt. Nineties beautiful.
January convertible 75
[inaudible] 75. It's nice. I know.
It's a nice day to day.
It was 60 this morning when I woke up.
I had to get up early. It was 66 zero. Mm.
Yeah. That doesn't happen for us. No,
right now it's brutally hot. Yeah.
Well you guys get that
swampy hot. Too Nasty. Yeah.
That east coast hot is a
different kind of hot like Miami.
You don't even know what hot is until
you experienced Miami and August.
It might as well be in Africa. Even
the God damn jungle. You know, I,
we hear a funny car chase story. I want
to hear all your funny car chase stories.
Okay. How many got three? Okay.
So my first car chase,
this is,
this is how far after the guy having
some other dude's pants on, uh,
about a year. A year. So a
year. And so I have a partner.
You usually don't have partners
in Baltimore at a partner
on this particular day?
Yeah. You ride by yourself. What,
what does that to save money? Uh,
I think more of an omnipresence idea.
Oh, the more people that are more cops,
more cause it doesn't really work, I
think every jerk off in your car. No, no
one told me that. Real quick, just
to ask you. I would, I get bored.
So I have this partner, he looks like
Sammy Davis Jr. Oh Jesus. Great Guy.
Great Guy. We'd go to calls. Did
you call him Sammy Davis Jr? I mean,
maybe sometimes joking and he was dead.
He looked that bad.
You're kind of a Sinatra
when he was younger. Oh.
Can you see Sinatra when you're buying?
Nobody else thought of that.
Now hold on a second.
Pull up the Sinatra's Sinatra's mugshot.
He was a tiny dude. You know, snapchat
only weighed like 125 pounds. No, no, no,
not you. You're, you're handsome. Like
Sinatra muscular and big. I get it.
But being not tiny,
your, your average guy, but I'm
saying Sinatra was like 130 pounds.
He was like a tiny dude.
Look at that. Come on dude.
You're a little better looking than him.
I'll be honest. What is, where's his a,
what do they arrested him for it? Because
it was like a little card that had the,
uh, there's a thing below it. There was a,
I used to have it on my wall at
home actually. It's not that one,
but uh,
he was arrested and it had its site
and wait for carrying on with a married
woman. Yeah, yeah. It was
called seduction. That's
what he got arrested for.
But that's not the,
there was actual real piece of paper
from the arrest that you can, uh,
you could see they had it like handwritten
and everything when he was arrested
for, see if we could find
it. But it had his, uh,
his height and weight and I'm pretty sure
he's 130 pounds and he was like five,
six or five, seven. He's like a tiny
little dude, which I never would thought.
I thought, you know, Frank Sinatra would
be like, it's just larger than life,
you know? I mean like Tom
Cruise kind of thing. No,
I think Tom Cruise is probably not as
short as everybody says. Right? Yeah.
I mean he might be a little
shorter, like five, seven may be,
but everybody said he's like five too.
People are just mean. Creem my partner,
he was about five, two, five, three. Oh,
Sammy Davis Jr Jesus Christ. And he would
cop, what does he punish me as? Good.
Yeah. So good. Cause he planted then
like nobody noticed him. Oh right.
And when he wa yeah, no one's
scared of five to Buckeye. Right.
We would go to places and he would be
the nicest cop. I mean, he was like,
like what you think the top is? That
was him. He was so nice, so courteous,
and I'd show up behind me like
sit down and shut the fuck up. Oh,
you're a bad cop. He would
get the complaint. I wouldn't.
Unbelievably hilarious.
I don't know why. It was just a
running joke with us cause he bought,
I can't throw that conjecture out there,
but most likely I would have
thought of that I thought was just,
they didn't like it or they liked me.
I don't know.
I never thought of it
as being a racial thing.
So we're going down a road and we
type a tag in a car and it comes up,
boop, boop, boop. The stolen
car. Oh Shit Dude, it's fucking
dog. Are we going to do,
why would it be whispering? I don't know.
But you start to panic. And I was like,
all right,
fuck it.
Let's just get out and I'll just yank
him out of the car real quick because
we're stuck in traffic. Right? So go
out. As soon as I jumped out of the car,
looks over at
me, the driver of the car, and
he slams down his, his lock
door lock. I'm like, fuck.
So I tried to rip the door open and
I can't do it. So for some reason,
instinctually I pull out my guide and I'm
like, get out of the car. And he's like,
no, fuck you. And it starts to turn
green and these get ready to go.
So I take my gun and I
hit it against the window.
The window doesn't break my gun.
Does the rounds go flying on the ground,
scattering out? And this is like noon.
And so everybody sees me doing this.
Like a jackass,
a glock 20 plastic plastic gun.
Why don't you hit her fucking window?
Fucking thinking.
So instinctually,
luckily I reload right and he takes off.
We run back into the car and we're
not going anywhere. I'm like, cream?
What the fuck? Let's go. And he's like, I
can't find the keys. I can't find a king.
Know. So he gets the key. We
take off, we go down the road.
What kind of car do you drive? It was
a, it was a crown Vic at the time. Okay.
Shitbox we cops love graphics.
Yeah, but there's 58 in them. Dude.
Big fucking goofy car, Shitty, shitty.
His front wheel drive Taurus's and shit.
They tried to give us fuck no drop. We
go down the road, the guy makes a turn,
we lose him.
But we kind of know his area where
he is and I see a guy that's running,
he had a blue Bandana on, he
was black guy, white t shirt.
So I see a guy going down the alley, blue
Bandana, white t shirt like fuck cream,
get out. So he gets out and he's
coming from the guy who behind.
I circle around with the car and
come up and I come around the corner.
That guy's looking at me and I'm like,
get on the ground.
And he starts getting on the ground
and I'm looking at him, I'm like, fuck,
this is,
this is not the same guy.
So I'm watching and creams coming up
behind him and he's like, come in hard.
I'm like, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Just as he's getting ready to hit him
and he pulls back and just get ready to
slam it to the ground, like this
is not him. So we leave him go,
we run it and we,
we actually find the car.
So the guy bowed out and he'd
left his cell phone in the car.
So we picked up the cell phone and we
called the most recent number and a girl
answered and we were like,
Hey, oh, I'm so and so.
I found this phone on the side of the
road. Do you know what belongs to,
I tried to get it back to
[inaudible] and she's like, oh yeah,
that's so and so for him up in the, in the
computer. And that was who had the car.
So he, oh my God, I'd be
so mad at her. I be like,
what the fuck did you tell him? Oh
my God, you told my fucking name.
All my God in the report and everything.
Oh that's hilarious. Did you get the Guy?
If somebody else did, so we
had the warrant. Somebody
else ended up catching him.
That's hilarious. That was your
first car check? First car chase.
Why don't they give you guys like
mustangs or something fast? Ooh,
I think that'd be a bad idea. Why not?
Very responsible. Is that what it is?
The law. We're not trained to drive
like that. Uh, the law, wait a minute,
hold the fuck on. They don't train you
how to drive. Not Highspeed. No, no.
They let you drive high speed chases.
They know you're breaking the rules
to do a high speed chase in Baltimore,
you can't do more than 10 miles
an hour was in Maryland. You
can't do 10 more than 10 miles an hour
over the speed limit according to the
rules.
So the law says you can do it,
but the rules of the agency say you
can only do 10 miles an hour over.
So every cop that pulls you over and
you're doing more than 10 miles per hour
over the speed limit,
he had the violate general orders
even pull you over was the rules.
I didn't make them. Okay. So the
department lets you do high speed chases.
They don't like it. No. But
so who lets you do it some,
you said you do it so somebody
tells you no. Okay. But they don't,
no one teaches you how to drive.
We go to a course and they kind of do it,
but the standards are incredibly
low and you don't go very fast.
So the standards for driving,
are they more or less stringent
than the standards for self defense?
I don't think there's a
standard in either. Um,
so that is so fucking
crazy. Right? If you,
if you couldn't defend yourself going in,
you're not going to have to
defend yourself coming out.
If you couldn't drive going in,
you're not going to drive coming out.
If you couldn't shoot going in,
you're not going to shoot coming out when
the scariest things is is cops ability
to fire a weapon. They're
terrible. They're terrible.
So I would estimate that may have
to be accurate or anything. No,
no, it's, it's, it's absurd.
Like they can't shoot.
So like when you hear somebody like,
why didn't you shoot him in the knee
for one, you, you can't do that. That's,
that's a silly idea.
But why can't you? Okay.
So if I'm shooting for
what I'm shooting at Uni,
I'm shooting down so I'm liable to
ricochet. I cause I'm gonna miss it.
You're going to be a moving target. You
know how hard it is to shoot an animal.
So imagine shooting a human in such a
tiny area that's trying to shoot with a
handgun. Right? You can't do
it. It's, it's a silly idea.
That's why you shoot sooner.
Center mass people criticize that,
but it's really the only
practical way to do it.
But she used to shoot animals to get,
very rarely shoot it out.
Imagine that even if he was standing
there and as we tried to take out a knee
cap of a boar sitting there,
that's, that's ridiculous. So,
so hopefully one day we can all dispel
that rumor about shooting a weapon at
somebody. I'd be like, why didn't you
shoot the knife out of his hand? Like,
are you kidding me? That's
hilarious. But they don't shoot,
they couldn't shoot a person,
let alone a neat, right. Like we,
the standard, a minimum score is like
a 70 and it's a silhouette target.
Like I minimum score meaning 70%
70% or when a silhouette you're,
no.
Okay.
So you go to hit the wholesale away from
the three to the five to the seventh to
the 15th I can shoot that whole course of
the 15 with my eyes closed and pass it.
Right. 15 yards. Is it?
That is so 15 yards with a handgun
hitting center mass on a tar.
All you have to do is just hit the target.
You can pass the course by
doing everything from the
three to five and I think
the seven it could be running is
this target. It's a human silhouette.
So I mean it's a full
silhouette for of the toast.
So you're dealing with like a two and
a half foot, three foot target. Yeah.
That's almost impossible to miss.
And all you have to do is
get 70% and you pass. Yeah.
So you miss 30% at 15 yards
a giant fucking targets.
We're not even talking about 15 yards.
We're talking about,
I mean some of these from three, wait
a minute. You start from the three,
you do a lot of random,
they get set.
Hold the fuck on 70% right?
So you can actually qualify before
you even shoot any person I know.
So this isn't even adrenaline.
There's not even grazes ideal situation,
ideal circumstances.
So that's all it should be.
100% I know a hundred or they kill you.
They should kill you from it.
Take you a bag. Yeah, a hundred
very good. A different tribe.
I've had 98 from time to time.
They shouldn't be there.
It's staggering.
People don't understand what we're
talking about when you say the job is
impossible,
it is completely impossible.
Especially with the amount of
training that they have. Oh my God,
I don't understand how they
don't train you how to do that.
They don't train you how to firearm
use firearms correctly. No. Nobody.
Accuracy treating you how to
breathe while you're shooting.
They tell you all these things,
but they don't have time.
So the instructors, they know what they're
doing, right? They don't have time to,
to take somebody that has no idea what
the hell they're doing or what's even
worse. And somebody has bad habits and
break those habits so they can be a decent
shooter. It's, it's, it's, there's no
time for it and it's not gonna happen.
There's those standards.
So if they don't pass,
they just keep shooting them and shooting
and shooting and shooting till you
pass.
So you just keep,
keep doing it or you learn learning to
learn and you only do it once a year.
What,
what the fuck are you talking about?
No practice once he oh
no. Yes. Oh my God. Right.
That's why I'm saying I couldn't do
this job without the Marine Corps.
So the only reason I'm,
I was any good that from the record.
How many guys were in the
service that you worked with? Um,
uh,
maybe 20% so 80% have no experience
hit the broad side of a barn.
Oh my God.
So these people are in this situation
where they had these expectations and
that's why they feel so cornered.
So they're actually feeling like they're
being somebody who's judging them and
it's not so much that they're
judging them. They're judging the,
the ineptitude to do the job.
It's a will Ferrell movie.
You could do it. I mean that's what it
feels like cops say about the banter.
I mean that's really, it's, it
seems that way a lot. God Damn it.
I can't believe that. Well why don't
I know that. I should have known that.
I got to get John McCarthy on. He's the
next cast, you know big John McCarthy.
He's got,
I got to get him on soon.
He got to tell him he's got some great
stories about pulling over Eddie Murphy.
I don't know.
I'm an Eddie Murphy Fan.
I will only speak with him about
him with respect and Charlie Murphy
anyway,
so no self defense training.
What is there is just
pointless.
You don't have to have like a certain
degree of proficiency in hand to hand
combat. No, they do like, I like
wrist locks and carries this one,
stuff like that. But this slot,
these are things that, you know,
in a real scenario we can't do.
So you gotta be a bad motherfucker.
Yeah.
You can do drill and put me to the
ground with my wrist. But in real life,
you'll never get in my wrist. Yeah.
It's just not going to happen.
If I'm fighting for my life
where I'm trying to get away,
it's just not gonna happen. So the
things we do just are impractical. Well,
Steven Seagal could get you to the ground.
Yeah.
Have you ever seen him seen as trying
to get to see the most recent one in
Russia? I'm afraid so I flipped
a bunch of people around.
I'm sure his hair didn't move.
One serious hair helmet he's got,
he's still nicely overweight.
Oh yeah. He's beautiful.
Beautiful fucking machine.
Can hand combat. Watch this,
take a look at this. I like to do rag
sweat, that sweet. Do Rag, look at this.
See this is what you guys need to learn
this kind of shit. Can you do that?
This is the kind of stuff they do and
they don't factor in the fact that they're
suspect is going to hook you in
the face with that empty left hand,
but wait a minute, look how this guy
can't do anything. I know. It's amazing.
It's almost like learned this,
this before to be the victim in
this situation. You can't. No Man.
I'm telling you,
you got to get Steven Seagal.
Teach everybody because look at the
way he just throws everybody around.
They have no chance. Look, he
doesn't even move. Dude. Learn this.
Why can't you just have empathy?
Isn't he a cop?
I thought he was too like a
voluntary one. No, he was a real cop.
I remember in Louisiana every,
he was talking like he was black.
If you keep talking about this,
somebody, I think he's transformational.
I think he's Trans Racial.
Did you ever hear him talk?
You're saying this now,
but then there's going to be some agency
that does that and thought it was a
good idea. It's all your fault. Should
look at this. This is beautiful.
If you could do this,
you could kick everyone's ass.
They don't even let them in the
UFC because he's too deadly.
We've had discussions behind closed door
meetings whether or not we should allow
Steven Seagal a fight
and everyone says no,
he's too deadly to take her out and
they need him for that is too small.
I'd in a different weight class
became Velasquez would be fucked.
Junior dos Santos. What's
you gonna do to that? Huh?
What are you going to do
with Fabrizio for doom?
Steven Seagal gets a hold of your wrist.
Huh? I haven't heard you tax wrists.
That's a very vulnerable spot and
I'll out like pull your hands on.
Isn't Joe Rogan doing it? Why don't
I have fire? Why don't you teach? No,
why don't you teach the cops?
Well,
I don't think I'm qualified because
I've never been in armed situation with
people shooting guns. I've never
learned how to disarm anybody in hand.
We don't need to arm. We don't
do this. I could, you know,
I copied my opinions about some shit,
but you should bring in legit striking
coaches that teach people all the time
and then legit Jujitsu coach Jujitsu.
It would be,
or your route because it's more
about control than depends. Hurting.
Well, yes, but no. Sometimes
you get to hit people,
like there's sometimes the idea of
only defending yourself by grappling.
I think mixed martial arts is the best
way to learn self defense. And uh,
I mean,
I'm essentially a mixed martial artists.
I started out as a striker and then when
I got older, when I got into the UFC,
that's when I really
learned grappling. But, uh,
I think if I had to choose one martial
art that I would teach someone to defend
themselves,
it would definitely be Jujitsu.
But as far as what I would
teach police officers,
you got to understand striking because
if you don't understand striking and a
guy who can keep you off him and punch
him in the face and you don't know how to
deal with it, you got to understand
the way he's moving. Like if a guy,
if a guy is going to jab you,
there's a certain stance.
If a guy's going to throw a right
hand, there's tells. If you don't know,
those tells you.
Just going to get Molly whopped.
You're just going to get cracked.
I think you have to understand at least
understand striking and the only way to
understand striking is this bar. You
have to do some sparring. You have to,
you have to definitely learn
the mechanics of striking,
but you also have to
understand the distance.
You have to understand how when a
guy can hit you, when he can hit you,
even if it's just defensive,
even if you don't have any intention
whatsoever hitting somebody,
just knowing how to get
the fuck out of the way,
knowing how to cover yourself up,
knowing how to protect herself.
There's a lot of people out there that
are grapplers that we'd be fucked if
someone punched him in the face.
No, I think you're onto something with
that actually like a the defensive method.
We're not going to really
teach cops to strike that.
You're just not going to get
anywhere. Best way you're, you're,
you're right to the,
like the, the getaway.
You might actually be on to something
there that that could be that that's
something we should probably should
be doing because what we do is we fear
things, so remember we fear
that that guy can hit us.
We fear that should have an understanding
of whether he or she would actually be
capable at that range are capable.
In this particular situation.
Judo is good for cops to because people
most of the time are wearing clothes and
like if you've ever fought Ronnie Ronda
Rousey and you were wearing a fucking
like a, like a winter coat, that bitch
would fuck you up. You're going flying.
You landed on your head,
Carl Prezi and gets a hold of you
and you got like a leather jacket on.
That mother is going to throw
you and hit you with the earth.
That's what it's like
when someone slammed you.
They're taking the earth and
hitting you with it. Boom.
They're hitting you with a giant and
mobile fucking 24,000 mile and assert
circumference ball. That's what they're
doing it the earth doesn't give.
Someone slams you in the concrete.
They literally hitting you with the earth.
And I think of a judo
person gets a hold of you.
Some Jimmy Pedro character gets a hold
of you and you have a winter jacket on,
you're a fuck Ceville you know,
that's uh,
I think Judah would be a very
important thing to learn wrestling.
Very important to learn to because if
you could hold someone down and it keeps
coming down and you can control someone,
cause I've seen situations where cops
get flipped and they're holding someone
down in some sort of a,
an arrest video and they just have no
idea how to control someone's body.
They have no idea where
to place their weight.
They have no idea like
how a person would move.
Like it good Jujitsu guy gets a hold
of you and puts you inside control.
You don't have any Jujitsu training,
you're not getting up. This is it.
You're stuck. I mean you might
be like really physically strong.
You might be able to
push them a little bit,
but he's going to grab a hold of
you again and repeat the process.
And that's what we saw in UFC one
when hoists Gracie was fighting chemo.
What do we see? We saw this fucking
enormous steroid it up, dude.
It's way stronger than hoists
Gracie and he just chaos.
But eventually always got them.
And why did he get him? Got Him.
Cause he understands the technique
and you understand how to grapple.
I think that from one, if you only had
one, I would say Brazilian Jiu Jitsu.
But if I was gonna teach
something to comps,
I would definitely teach them striking.
The last thing you want to do is be
someone who doesn't know how to strike and
you get punched in the face and you're,
you're seeing stars,
you're eyes are watery,
your legs are buckled and you
don't know what the fuck to do.
Cause he never been there before.
Somebody knows what to do.
Someone who's been there before has been
popped in the face before you got to go.
Oh, all right, got to keep my
hands up. Gotta move. Gotta
move gotta move. You know,
you'll instinctively have like a path
that you'll go to to preserve yourself.
The,
the scariest thing in the world is
watching someone in a street fight and you
know, they don't know how to
fight and they just, their,
their neck is up in the air and they're
flailing fists and you know, it's coming,
you know, you know it's coming
and we've all seen videos.
You can go online and watch.
Guy Gets Kod and street fight and
there's a million videos of that.
I just can't believe that they don't
force you guys to train first of all in
firearms on a regular base. I would
always thought that'd be a weekly thing.
I really thought that there was like a
weekly thing that you guys had to do the
physical standards as well.
Yeah,
I've seen a lot faster because there's
not a physical standard whatsoever.
Well how about chicks? Oh, have
standards. They don't have to have a, the,
you don't have to at least be able to
like lift their body weight or something
or do a chin up or something like that.
You get through the academy
and you're finished.
What do you have to do to get through
the academy or whatever. It is.
Pathetic and easy. That
seems weird. It is weird. Uh,
and in Baltimore they had an issue with
a fire cadet who ended up dying and
training because they,
they just didn't maintain the physical
standards they needed to make.
Now why is that? Is it hard to get
people to join the police force?
So you have to lower
the physical standards.
One reason why the job was impossible
there. Society doesn't seem to be willing.
Okay. So at this point in time,
not to sound too arrogant.
Too late. Too late. Okay. So
it's amaze. Well, go for it.
I would be the prototype.
Okay. I have a master's degree.
I'm confident I came from
the, from the military. Uh,
if you go through my training record,
you'll see it. It's all there.
I would be the prototype. I'm what
you're looking for, but I still,
you're not willing to pay me what it would
take to get somebody like me normally
to do it. So, so if you, right now,
if I went to a police department,
they would be offering me
$42,000 a year. Really? I mean,
you don't think I'm going to take away
2000 a year job to you at this point in
time. It's not going to
happen. So, so they're not
investing in those officers.
I really think in a,
in most areas where like a Baltimore,
you have 3000 officers,
I really think you could do
the job with a thousand. So,
so you would pay those guys,
get those guys and you'd get the guys
with the education and girls and have
those standards.
And I really think that one really,
really good cop can do the job of
the four or five of what we have now,
how much harder is it to be a woman
and be a cop? Incredibly hard.
Imagine, be really hard to get people.
Some of them are so freaking good though.
Um, so that's the weird line. You tow.
They do seem to make better detectives.
Um, as a general rule, they have
an advantage and a lot of things.
I think they're more empathetic, which is
one of my big pushes. They're, they're,
they're more considerate
of others when it,
when it comes to a lot and it's
harder for them with fighting.
But I've seen some of them
hold their own just fine.
And the hardest one was
actually a flamboyantly gay
cop than I know he had the
hardest time and I loved that
guy. Flamboyantly gay cop.
I love him so much. He Gay. Was he very,
he's the queen and so he referred to,
he calls himself the claim is the queen
of the northern. That's beautiful.
That's what we need to stop fucking
army of roided up gay cops and he's,
he would fight all the time.
If you could go to battle with that
dude any day and you could trust that he
would have your back,
you could follow him day and night.
Cause he was tried constantly and
he became, he was always good.
Love that dude. Awesome cop
to work with. But he was,
he constantly lived in a
different world than I did.
I was maybe I fell into that medium frame
where like I'm not too big to try and
I'm not too small to try.
So I kind of got away with a lot because
she was tried all the time because he's
flamboyantly gay. Yeah. So did he be
like license and registration? He was,
he has the voice, so he really say that
when he pulled people over and stuff.
Oh yeah. Well you going and he had a
purse for a while. Let me think about,
think about that though. I
love it because you do it, but
that's true. I actually
don't know. I don't know.
Maybe cause you gave it to me. I think I
do, but I thought about that. The airport,
like you say,
it's like if it would be so much easier
that people are just scared of not
getting laid,
that's why they don't have it.
They're scared of the fashion stigma
attached to it. It's bullshit.
It's what it is.
I wear one of those mother
fuckers everywhere and then
meet me and they go, dude,
you really wearing a fanny pack.
I'm like, that's right bitch.
That shit's real as fuck.
Why is that? Why is that a
problem? But if I wear a backpack,
I'm saying it's that same confidence
that you have with the confidence that he
has. Cause I'm married, I'm not
trying to get laid. It was admirable.
If I was struggling to try
to get laid, I was like, man,
it was window and hit her mess. I was just
had to be dressed perfectly. You know?
That's what I do to wear Cologne and
shit like that. And designer shoes. Why?
Cause they fucking trying to
tip the scales in their favor.
They're not confident in their personality
and their accomplishments and how
they come off as,
as a human being.
They've got to get to wear the right
clothes and the right style and that fanny
pack and fucking sick your
battle. Chet dammit. I had her,
she could have been the one that married,
had kids.
I was that fucking stupid panty
fanny pack. I fucked my chances.
I don't know if that's why.
I think you've got enough game.
You can do it with a fanny pack.
That's what I think.
I think if a girl doesn't
want to have sex with you,
it doesn't want to date you
because you have a fanny pack.
You don't want her in your life. She's
too much work. That's too much work.
Or you don't know how
to make fun of yourself.
You can't even mock the fact that you
were in a fanny pack and then explain
yourself can make a good show. And she's
like, why are you wearing a fanny pack?
Stupid. You're like, exactly.
Anyway, he wore a purse. Yeah,
he keep this kind of purse goes it
like glittery or anything. He had it.
It would have been stylish. It
wasn't, it wasn't no chump shit.
So, um, what, what was it like for him?
I mean I think it was
incredibly challenging for him.
Like they wouldn't let him arrest him.
Like they would fight like,
like no way. I understand I'm
going to jail but not from him.
Is He still on a job? Yeah, he's awesome.
Too. Good for him. What's his name?
I don't know. Just give his full
name. His first name. No, no.
I just want to give a shout out to him.
You can call que que you keep it sexy,
keep it sexy queue.
So harder for him than
women. Yeah, I think so.
I think it's incredibly hard for him.
And she was saying that women make better
detectives. What, what else besides
empathy? Do they have like intuition? It's
better.
I mean I can't say but they s they do
seem to fulfill those roles very well.
Hmm. Yeah. So there's a role
for females in policing.
Even if you're thinking of the
physical aspects, uh, there,
there is a like a need. Right?
So how you balance that?
I can't say that it required a little
more nuance, but definitely have a role.
Is there anything else you want
to say before we get out of here?
Cause I know you've got
a bunch of notes there.
It's just that one of the big things
that we see is everybody keeps fighting
against the black lives matter thing.
And it's like we're not
understanding what it is.
It's not that we come out
with things all lives matters.
Might wear a shirt all lives matter. No,
no shit. We understand all lives matter.
That's the whole point
of everything we do.
And they come out and they say
police lives matter. No Shit.
I don't know a life that's
mattered more than a police life.
I don't know of a single cop has been
killed or the killer wasn't called,
which is embarrassing for our profession.
Why do we always catch the
ones that hurt our own? Hmm.
Maybe we're not trying hard enough.
And the other ones,
and we go around and we say these things,
but the police, everyone comes to their
aid when something happens to them.
But when we, somebody says black
lives matter, we just, Oh, oh,
oh. But what they're, it's all they're
saying is, is that in our society,
black lives haven't mattered as much
as the other lives. And that's clear.
When you see something like Tamir Rice,
because you know that doesn't
happen then one of your kids,
there's not a shot in hell that that
happens to my daughter or yours. No Way.
Whether there are 12 year olds sit with
a BB gun in the middle of your street in
front of your house. That is not going
to happen because they're going to say,
oh well no you don't.
We're going to handle that situation.
We're going to approach her.
We're going to see what's really going on.
And they're not going to be a hero because
a hero is the person that goes up to
Tamir rice and approaches
and tries to figure it out,
risk getting shot because he wants to
make sure he's doing the right thing.
When you take away a life or
take away somebody's freedom,
you don't even have to go up to them.
How about you just say from the comfort
of the car, put down the gun. Sure, sure.
From far away, you know, figure it
out because w but we go and we, we,
we treat black lives like they don't
matter. And when you were putting that,
oh yeah,
all lives matter shirt on or oh yeah,
police lives matter on your proving
that police lives don't, that,
that black lives aren't
mattering as much to you.
Otherwise you would just
fucking say, yes they do. Right.
So they're not saying that white lives
don't matter. Let matter. Bring it up,
bring it up to everyone else.
That's it. Just a quality. It's not,
it's not a dis on anybody else.
It's we have this problem and we
have this problem. Recognize it,
let's fix it. That's when I say
that I want to team up with the ray.
So if I took a uh, police commissioner
job, the first thing I would do is say,
Deray, please come join me
please because I need you.
I need him.
He's a community leader.
The idea that we don't integrate
people like him into our system is
ridiculousness. He is a leader of
the black community. I need him.
If I'm going to run a police agency and
we should not be turning those kinds of
people away and acts
and making like there,
there was some kind of instigators from
Abbott town is what they would call the
instigator.
That's what they call them out of town,
instigator that he was coming to Baltimore
and he's making money and he's doing
all this and it's not an
equal one and he's doing,
they think he's making money doing all
this and he's simply not. Neither am I.
I mean we came out here on our
own arm dime with the help of,
well you know who's making money?
That's how sharp and CNN and Fox News,
anybody broadcasting it where they're
going to get advertising dollars and
that's something that's going to get a
lot of people watching certainly is our
ratings went up.
I went down to where Freddie gray was,
the incident happened and where
the uprising was the very next day.
You couldn't have told me that there was
a difference between that day and two
weeks ago.
The problem is that no one gave a shit
about Gilmore homes two weeks ago,
but when it comes on the news and you
saw the cvs burning and they cycled it
over and over and over again, it was
one God damn building that was burning.
You just kept seeing it over and over
after the fire department had already put
it out. Violence in violence in Baltimore,
the riots and all of these tapes,
that fucking news
voice,
you're your own and exactly.
And we do that and then we look at that
community and we're like, oh my God,
why would they do that? Well, nothing ever
happens without it. Without an uprising.
What ever great civil rights movement or
great progress if we ever made without
some kind of uprising. How about
the United States of America? Yeah.
This came about because we got
away from the fucking British.
I mean that's literally how this
got started. It was an uprising.
Boston tea party. It's a goddamn uprising.
And is anybody sit there and say,
oh my God, why did they just throw
their own tea in to the water?
That's ridiculousness.
But they don't hesitate to say,
why are they burning that cvs down?
Well that's the only symbolism
of corporate America that
they even have their,
cause they don't have a grocery
store like you and I do.
They don't have anything that
we think of as as as normality.
They live in a, in an area that has food
deserts, that doesn't have good schools,
where the kids ride MTA buses to go to
school where the life is and, and their,
their parents get,
their father gets locked up because he
has that dime bag and he perpetuates a
cycle,
but yet society keeps telling them or
we'll pick yourself up by your bootstraps
and I'm fucking have bootstraps because
you took them away by your boobs.
Judge is such a shitty argument. It's not
like everybody starts in the same spot.
You know?
It's not like we're all playing monopoly
and we all start from the same spot.
It's stupid.
That's such a terrible,
terrible mentality that people have and
it's so short sided and so dismissive.
Pull yourself up by your bootstraps.
It's just so dumb. It's such a short,
and that's a short sided conservative
argument that is a conservative argument.
It's just such a dumb one.
Well,
the last thing I wanted to say too is
that conservatives and right wing people
are the ones that are going
to argue with me the most.
If we don't do what I'm saying,
then they're going to lose their guns and
their argument that they want to have.
Because if we can't reel in police and
they're always afraid that everyone has a
gun and we have to do this war,
then that means we can't live in a society
that's armed and we can't police it
properly. You just said that a
bunch of people just look, Bro,
what the fuck lose my guns? Right? What'd
you say? Sorry. Should take my flag.
You're taking my fucking gun. Not,
nope. If you want to keep your guns,
Charlton Heston said,
yeah,
you can pry my cold dead hands
from it if you want. Well,
if you want to keep your guns,
then we need to have reform in policing.
I don't like this kind of language because
people are going to keep their guns.
They're keeping the fucking
gun unless reform policing.
I think that's a great idea. I don't
think you need to bring guns into this.
You know, guns and do anything to anybody.
What did the cops can on people. People.
People are doing it. People kill
people. People are killing people.
Guns are just sitting
there looking beautiful.
How many gun deaths happened in England?
Ah, fucking English. Bunch of pussies.
Scared to pull the trigger. So the
argument though, it has a funny
imagine. We turns out they all
had guns. I can't quite do it.
I was thinking about shooting just
doesn't seem Brian who's Robert Wright
wouldn't be proper.
Yeah, no, I, uh, listen,
I think you're saying some awesome things.
We do have to wrap this up, but uh,
I really, really appreciate you
coming on and I think you, uh,
you express yourself very well and uh,
I think that you're,
you're a very unique person.
Your perspective is very unique.
The fact that you have so much
experience and you're, you're,
you're saying all the right things.
So thank you very much. I really,
really appreciate it. Um, you could
catch him on Twitter. Michael A.
Wood Jr.
M I C h a e l a wood w.
O o d junior. Um, last
thing. Anything else? Yeah,
I mean, this is a great, no, this is
not about me. This is about the point.
Where's the best place for people to
reach you? Just Twitter. Just Twitter.
This is not about me. This is about the
message. I appreciate that very much.
Michael would junior ladies and gentlemen,
a bad motherfucker.
You have been schooled.
See you guys soon.